[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
guys what up guys we got action on the
game everybody here has action on the
game you guys at home have action on the
game drop your locks drop the picks in
the chat and we are all gonna talk about
them uh we have the whole Squad here the
whole Squad is in the building I'm gonna
uh introduce them we got the app guys
how are we doing we got Logan my boy
Michael Boling right there we got viral
Vinnie viral Vinnie Mick whatever you
want to call our viral V
wherever there's a viral moment there's
Vince yes sir we got my man Bryson in
the back
he might be the the the the the mayor of
of what's what city out there in Kansas
Lawrence Kansas Lawrence Kansas the
mayor of Lawrence Kansas everybody out
there knows Bryson and then we got to
the far of you guys right my far left my
man producer Ryan how he living man How
We Living producer Ryan I'm feeling
pretty good man yes sir
as you guys can see
Joe's girlfriend
producer Ryan please pull up our bets
for the people at home football our bets
so we got too many bets just to just to
hit the mall there they go so we'll ask
for everyone's best bet in a second but
we gotta touch on the squad no Score
first drive which as of this moment guys
looks pretty good looking got our
anytime touchdown boost on Cordell
Patterson on DraftKings that's up to
plus 200 and then our same game parlay
that is seven to one odds Mariota 30
plus rushing yards Drake London 40 plus
receiving yards PJ Walker the
interception machine just at the 001 and
DJ Moore 55 plus receiving here there it
is hold on before we get started I know
we got the no Score first drive third
and seven we're in good shape and how's
everybody feeling about that very
confident everybody's feeling good about
that all right I need to know
everybody's best bet starting with
Logan My Man Logan give us your best bet
of the night I'm going with Tyler
algiere anytime TD Cordero feasted last
week I just think it's time for my boy
to get some there it is that's one baby
yeah bro we got no Score first draft
what's wrong
you're an eye guy
all right I guy go ahead Bryson tell us
your best bet of the day
what is it over three and a half
reception okay okay I'm happy for you 30
yards
right I'm happy for you my man Bryson is
in the building viral V I hope hey
you're in the building I hope we go
viral tonight oh we will we have a very
good chance what's your best bet of the
night bro uh we're going uh under all
the way up with this weather come on the
game it's like yeah no chance
you're kind of hesitant saying that you
like no no no I feel very locked in I
feel very good yeah
hey viral V gotta keep that straight
face because you know points you never
know when you can go viral you never
know my man Michael Bolin please I got
Grady Jarrett over 0.75 sacks it's two
to one odds both of these quarterbacks
are bad man he's gonna get to PJ Walker
for sure and we're catching two it's an
Uncle Matt all right there it is
no Score first drive is still in effect
third and long Bryson please do not
cheer if they get a first down I won't
unless it's called pitch
yeah let's get a check hey Brian uh give
us your best bet of the night bro yeah
so you said you weren't gonna be a hater
I will be a hater uh Kyle Pitts under
three and a half percent
I love that energy I love that energy at
the watch party hey man we are trying to
catch this first bet if you guys don't
know we got the no Score first Drive
come on let's go down
I need fist in the comments Ryan let me
know if there's Fists in the comments
because that's a checkbook that is a
check mark fourth down no Score first
drive we all just cashed
all right let's check out the chat D
Phillips D Phillips wants to know how
windy is it uh we don't know
Google
somebody can Google it and see
a good punt takes us right to the
cashier
we go I'll be the weather man shout out
to all right we got it I'll go get it
all right all right we cashed on the no
Score first drive guys we're hot we're
hot we're red hot uh hey Ryan can you
give us some live odds brother live live
odds can we get some live odds while he
pulls up right now he's blowing let's
talk over some live odds and see if
anybody's wants some action
yeah so we're on DraftKings right now uh
after the first after the first drive
Falcons punts it away not a very good
punt but they've moved from minus two
and a half to minus one so over over 39
and a half so yeah some some people like
to get in after that first drive you
know what I'm saying and fill it out
bowling you said it the total is 39 and
a half I I don't know after that I might
take the under yeah oh my God are you
locking that in or are you just I'm just
saying it don't hold me don't hold my
feet my guy Michael Ritter be our
weather man okay just kidding my Apple
app uh 11 miles an hour west southwest
okay
sources have confirmed that the uh the
wind is blowing 11 miles per hour in the
stadium so a lot of a lot of reporters
would probably say 10 to 12 miles an
hour isn't going to do very much but if
it picks up I'll be your guy so anyone
anyone in the chat who needs a weather
update hit me up and I got it we got it
all we got locks we just cashed a bet we
got Bryson bringing us good bad vibes
when we need Good Vibes we have Michael
Gold bringing us weather reports and we
have viral Vinnie checking his text
messages
because we probably already
stop right off the first drive sitting
pretty baby how are you feeling hey I'm
feeling good man Cordell Patterson I got
him to score I don't like how we look
awesome I don't like how we looked
coming around Ryan has to help the chat
right now definitely like I'm about to
melt down with the chat we've got Sam
Richmond in here our King uh not my king
tonight uh Ryan thoughts on degrom to
the angels fake news didn't happen Mike
Steve Ritter degrom to Grom to the
Rangers in all caps if anyone is going
to jump in this chat tonight it could be
fake Jacob to Grom news I'm not going to
be happy Mike C Ritter just hopped in
Brandon Nemo to the Royals the Royals
don't spend money that's not even we're
not even sure we're not even gonna start
we haven't even gotten you said the
Rockies if you said the Mariners I'd be
sweating we're one drive in man you guys
gotta lock in that's that's our kid
right there PJ Walker anytime a lot of
bets talking a lot of bits plus they
don't have to be feeling great hey run
pass here run past anybody want a dollar
up it's already happened next play
okay I'll go run next play next play run
dollar hey so it's going to be for uh oh
the football field no that is a fumble
guy fumble second and second in like
five or six we gotta lock it in now guys
I'm run run past Bryson my action pass
you guys are out I got a screen pass
coming pass uh this is a run all right
so we got two runs two passes I'm out of
it Ryan producer Ryan's out of it
I mean can we just talk about these
black helmets
absolutely stunning matte black yeah
never a doubt shout out to you guys sir
it's a Dollar Bet Dollar Bet
oh probably should we keep a running
count yeah we do need a PJ Walker
interception and they may just never
never throw it we also need a PJ Walker
anytime touchdown so and first well
don't say we you we as relative yeah the
Royal we
I do I need it yeah but for sure shout
out these black all right so so which
which was better these in the NFL
helmets or the Bengals white altar
Bangles for sure that was icy they they
were incredible did you see those
Bengals on Thursday night uh White icy
white yeah they're just not gonna throw
the ball there so so he was Vince asked
which ones were better these black
uniforms are the Bengals ice bottles I
swipe I think it was the Bengals yeah
the Bengals I was looking they was
looking fresh in those whites yeah
they're fresh but I mean the Bengals
have players that people know nobody
knows it hey look at Ben McAdoo isn't
that you oh no ball coach at uh New York
that's fine good riddance that's what
bigger and better things now that's it
yeah
that's it Greg you do me a favor how
much time's left bro I can't see the
time nine minutes nine minutes in the
first quarter
and I don't want to call it too early
um yeah yeah go to the chat yeah I would
just like to thank Sam Richmond and uh
they said work he said he doesn't want
to jump back starting the degrom trend
because now I have Zay 23 to grow up to
the Pirates so she's not gonna end
tonight it's not gonna end a pirates
have had an active day and the chat they
said producer Ryan is sweating right now
no DJ more yeah baby that looks like I
saw offensive holding offensive holding
that's DJ Moore
that looks a lot like okay so isn't that
a part of yourself
yeah that's our parlay for the people at
home I also have this under
yeah
a lot of conflicting things this is
exactly why this is a fun event because
if we were sitting at the crib we would
all have random bets anyway so so
producer Ryan can you tell the people at
home why you hate DJ Moore so much
because I don't get it sure so he has
ruined three consecutive fantasy
football seasons for me and I said No
More DJ more and then the fourth round
of my draft came around this year and I
was like okay More DJ more and then he
ruined another season so DJ this sounds
like a personal problem so no it's a
personal Vendetta didn't start him two
weeks ago when he called the help I
traded him already so so I traded him
and the person I traded him to started
him against beat me and beat me that
week okay I get it now so me and DJ Got
Us in the same room okay yeah
like the next like seven minutes or I
lose my first bet so well I have a field
goal within the first 13th you already
cashed the no Score first drive that's
true my second bet I'm trying to sweep
the board tonight man hey I got
you did yeah we did it we did a little
bit that's friends with him that's
friends yeah that was really good at it
it's cool cool dude he was not very good
for the Bears so whatever
we haven't had really good kickers since
Robbie Gold and now he's on the Niners
yeah I love our living legend he's as
good as gold he is he's always been man
second and ten seven minutes left Bryson
throws a duck oh that was our pick we
needed that
dude bro where are your hands out of his
hands what it what what's he saying
settle down for they couldn't play wide
receiver because they can't catch bam
hey we needed that one
come on hey and threw up he's open too
when he makes his break he's open
bro bro wow it couldn't hit you on both
hands helmet and chest oh no hey we
needed that for the parlay hey guys lock
in a lot of ball left
a lot of ball left no way
PJ Walker thumbs up like thanks for not
catching that third and ten seven
minutes left in the first quarter
incomplete
oh
yeah
hey I got a dollar that he misses this
bag how much time left you got to catch
what are the knives
seven minutes man I I think I have I
have young way cool
I'm sorry that wasn't even all right I
have the over one and a half field goals
for Eddie Pinero this is absolutely this
is big somebody should have been no
touchdowns
score too yeah that's 46 yards that's my
card come on come on six in the rain
come on Eddie
[Laughter]
[Applause]
let's go
The Vibes are high okay
wow I'm triggered let's go they said
hurricane
do they know who this man is
Ryan are you tracking are you tracking
your best yes 2-0
did you what did you do I had first
field goal within 14 minutes it's not on
the sheet prices it is it is is it yeah
in the middle wait can we pull up the
sheet please oh yeah pull up let's get
the sheet up please
Bryson has like eight yeah Bryce and I
know right oh yeah it's like seven
different vets hey man sometimes the
possibility of you yeah going 2-0
compared to us is like not fair it's not
fair all I hear is complaining y'all
could have sent Max seven bets too
that's true yeah would you imagine
anyone on this BR betting team actually
betting more than Bryson I don't think
it's no I don't know
if if anyone here is betting more than
me honestly I'm not comfortable
I'm not comfortable with that type of
exposure Bryson is wait so Bryce said
you're 2-0 yeah on what I got uh the
nsfd the nsfd is not up there but I had
the you in the chat room
Bryson's trying to add an nsfd up there
with his seven days sorry Greg am I or
am I not part of the squad let me know
I'll walk out like if I'm not let me
know to be honest with me because it
says it says
all right so you're definitely a part of
the squad but you can walk out though
pop it in the chat here uh one of two
things one uh Mal jumping in here saying
Ben McAdoo Ben McAdoo looks like a
general manager of a dine in only Pizza
Hut
the rare insult of that I mean that was
that was very detailed but two also if
you're in the chat drop us your best bet
for tonight we'll talk it through also
if you have a live play that you like
we'll discuss it maybe we'll bet it I'm
looking for a vlog I'm looking for a
live lock for sure
so I thought there was going to be
points scored in this game it's gonna be
way under you know I don't want to go
down a Ben McAdoo rabbit hole but just I
when I think of him I can't get that
oversized suit in that press conference
out of my mind and the really terrible
slickback haircut
um I'm scarred with Matt hey make sure
you guys fill in those comments keep
keep well commenting giving us live bed
ideas probably hates Ben McAdoo just as
much as you do because he said first
quarter first quarter pretending to be
an adult anybody had any Bryson did you
have first quarter action uh no I just
had that field goal Cordero
why is Cordell Patterson like their dog
horse like on offense and also a
returning kick he literally is the only
weapon they have
a lot of people don't like Kyle Pitts he
shouldn't be returning kicks he was
actually he is actually really good with
the Bears he's probably all time
return guy no but at this point in his
career he probably should stop exactly
right
I feel like uh Ryan I don't know like I
know we we don't need to put the bets up
there again but I feel like I'd love a
group discussion about the fact that
like I bet both sides of this game
basically for the Panthers to lose and I
respect that a lot and okay Mariota
that's a three that's three three okay
take it how many we need we need well
Thirty Thirty that's a start yeah you
got to start it's almost until the day
Jacob saying PJ Walker will be benched
that would not be great after he throws
an interception yeah like honestly he
already threw one yeah
PJ Walker benched
LGA yeah well Algeria whatever it is
French
Tyler how you say LGA
didn't you bet him yeah over 31 and a
half Russians like three yeah oh yeah
that was his first run I thought about I
think for one of my other parts this is
tough
so maybe we don't go undefeated tonight
yeah
what did you have him over 30 yards 31.5
got to leave room for improvement Ryan
you know that where's my boy Patterson
throw the ball pits throw the ball pits
yeah just no not Kyle
it's not a mere Bird yeah it's the
mirror not even Drake London guys I move
the chains no they they don't look at
London anymore
seventh pick of the draft they did
sounds like a good idea I got a way to
move to Chase
and I remember thinking to myself these
USC wide receivers don't usually do that
well didn't Drake I don't think it's a
big London is DJ more a USC one yeah no
no no all right pitch Birdman
hey you got to have some more call them
all the bits
no that's pretty amazing
incompetent Ryan what's the live line
good question
Panthers got to be the Pick Em Right
yeah
hold up hold up hold up
uh minus one yes jackham just said bird
cashed in over 10 yards there it is wow
that was the lock of the night free
money
all right what is this Lou mathie DJ
live on DJ over 55 and a half PJ over
163.5
we see you Lou mathie I think TJ's gonna
have a big game I bet him to have 75
receiving yards
I thought DJ Wisconsin
yards want to throw the ball to Kyle
Pitts man can we turn can we do that uh
what's up with my boy Cornell Patterson
where is he
yeah like yeah come on Coach I mean
let's figure it out later in the season
Cordero might be I'll might be limited
this game
I hope not yeah go go Tyler card is
depending on him
so that's good maybe they plan to use
them only in Red Zone which is a good
thing for us I mean scoring well yeah
this week right yeah they're using about
kickoffs they're gonna they're gonna use
that's what I'm thinking yeah that's a
good thought I mean you're gonna take
the most brutal hits there
this is when I start to panic and like
search Twitter just like search you guys
ever do that like your guy's not in the
game for two plays you just like you're
some scroll Twitter just search his name
you just search his name latest he's in
now we're good to see a bunches
right here fellas
they need to throw the ball to him
his over yards was reception yards young
white props
it's not a it's not a world it's over
all the rushing props it's done yeah
they can't block they're over
I it's one of those things like it's
like there's no point just Mark that as
an L tell Max Max I don't know if you
can hear me Mark as an L we're gonna
move on to the other six bets yeah it's
seven bets eight bets I played well for
you half the bets I didn't even tell you
guys about because I don't want anyone
to judge me I have a nice 12-leg parlay
made on DraftKings Sportsbook hopefully
it comes through but I need a lot of
things
a lot of things I need a Cordell
Patterson catch here guys
for seven yards for seven yards that'd
be awesome I just need Kyle Pittsford oh
there he is
oh
yeah
call back that's going back Ryan please
please tell me
definitely Ryan barked at me and he
honestly should have already lost the
bet
yikes what a good call what a good call
you say to yourself
no no no no Kyle Pit's under yeah me too
yeah yeah I can't be you guys you have
receptions or yards receptions or yards
around look at that look at that clean
bro you should have been ejected for
that hole falling already literally
falling already
you sound like you sound like Sam Sam
always like ejection
hit 84. he's open anyone but Kyle
no no no no no no
illegal oh nobody can catch him how did
you not catch them
young way
no it's too far no this is out of young
boys
they're like at the 50. oh he's got six
drops and Sprint it right
that's 60 yards right here hey this is a
punt though I got over I got the punt
over
I think they're gonna call another hold
here man it was over the line of
scrimmage yeah too no back foot was
behind it back foot was behind it
how is your best bet of the night not
over eight and a half months dude I I'll
be honest with you I wanted seven and a
half
when you told me he was eight and a half
I just felt like I was in a yes mood
again
only to climb it if they're gonna punt
though
punt please don't kick this ah
low scoring first quarter guys
if anybody has it under Vinnie unders
feeling good oh feeling pretty pretty
Jack I'm not happy about these DB's
hands
all right well they're pretty
straightforward yes that looks big I was
paraphrasing yeah here we go yeah Sam
jumping in the chat saying Panthers are
kind of sick it's a hard disagree
I mean their defense is very good
the Panthers yeah that's two it's an
underrated defense yeah do you not think
it could be the Falcons are just very
bad
um
well documented that's America's team
you're talking about seven and one no
again
I don't know how they've covered so many
spreads to be honest with you this
offensive line is worse than the Bears
and the Bears offensive line is really
bad they beat the Niners I can't believe
that fair weather I mean just about half
the teams the goofy game on them and the
Falcons it was a goofy game
wow I think all of our offensive props
for the Falcons are dead also I took
Falcon's money line and I don't feel
very good about it right now uh are they
plus money at this point
they're plus 105 if you want to double
dip
um
is is is is what Ryan let the people
know Falcons are plus 105 the total is
down to 36.5 oh my gosh
there's not gonna be a touchdown scored
in this game Bryce it I don't want to
and that would be really good for you
Ryan BJ walkers
yes I bet let the record show plus nine
thousand what's that record what's that
bowling uh no touchdown scored I bet
plus nine thousand right now
right that's what happened I mean we did
all looking online
we all talked about it if we didn't talk
about it before the game you would not
have made that bet okay
the same way you guys have access
got all my money and DraftKings don't
take a savings I got a question I got a
question what's that so this is this is
a conversation I've had with my homies
before like if you give me a lock and I
tripled or quadruple Max hammer it and I
win a bunch of money do you give your
homie a little cut no he's got the lock
a hug and five bucks nah
[Music]
you guys just sat here before and said
oh I would take the live under if I go
bet the live under and I bet
you have this under
yeah
oh no
we both have his under I totally forgot
I do have that too that's uh that's how
you know right now I got a conference
yeah
originally it was over and then I saw
the weather for tonight and I changed
okay all right catch you up on the chat
here Scotty boy saying do not that's a
run I'll take the Run do not double dip
on Atlanta money line so that's for you
bowling thank you uh Knox for MVP
Patterson anytime touchdown four minute
anytime touchdown Patterson over 50. I
don't know if he's watching the same
game that we are but a touchdown will
not be scored here yeah it doesn't look
like also knocks for MVP uh which knocks
is that are we talking Dawson Knox for
MVP is that what the username is
yeah what is that do we even know who's
throwing Dawson knocks the ball inside
yeah looking like Josh Allen yeah
reports out of Buffalo but guys
according to this game I mean look at go
greatest game the Panthers are coming
out
bro who is 21 Fenton what's that live
long look like Ryan Robert shot Finn
from the Chiefs he can't tackle the
Panthers are looking good yeah yeah
that's that's Rashad Fenton lost 130 on
the money line
it's a really good time for PJ Walker to
throw this pig hey if you guys are uh
thinking about it
Panthers are looking really good at this
job
yeah they're moving it moving The Rock
I don't know about them though
PJ Walker gonna throw it to the other
team again I think
but I really need Grady Jarrett to get
this sack out of the way so I could
be happy oh okay okay I need a punch I
need to punch
30 seconds in the quarter yeah we're
behind Pace fast quarter you better lose
one Bryson well I got over eight and a
half
punts
less punts in the second half in the
first half typically
okay yes yes so I need I need I need to
be at Five Thirteen inches are they
gonna snap this who puts going to the
second quarter baby in the half eight
and a half yeah all right hooker all
better is in the chat that had the under
go ahead and cash your ticket because
that's a wrap yeah right that under is
flush what's the live could not feel
better
then you want to try and uh try and
middle there on that over 35.
[Music]
I've been burned too many times
yeah there it is everyone's balance
should be freed up from no Score first
drive I know I got myself we have
someone
to be my ex-wife uh ask me anything
[Music]
um oh we also have your grandma in the
chat nice oh we got a question Ryan's
Grandma first time seeing this pod very
what's up Ryan's grandma doing this uh
welcome is anybody else sweating
Louisiana Lafayette money line
no no that's only you man well they're
winning if you were so just FYI all
right Bryson questions question in the
chat hey you got the handy dandy iPad
back there oh the handy dandy iPad there
it is you guys ready let's go is Cordero
Patterson Hall of Fame level from adoc
dannally no
I think there's an argument
as a return let's hear the arguments you
didn't get it Devin Hester didn't get in
yet but he will get in
I think that opens the door for
returners definitely won't be a first
ballot thing but if you look at the
actual over his career numbers he's got
I think 12 or 13 return touchdowns and
like seven or eight punt return
touchdowns that's pretty good
if you start putting in special teams
return guys after Devin Hester
you flip a coin maybe gets in on the
third ballot I don't know I'll make an
argument for it since you guys all say
that that was a pretty bad argument
you're like oh like not first like you
don't sound convinced of this yeah
you're trying to convince us I think
it's been super fascinating to watch him
become like a really strong like
starting caliber running back in like
the last two years
right after he left the Bears because we
couldn't use them yeah somebody couldn't
use it somebody finally figured out how
to use them yeah right and now he's a
touchdown scoring machine which we need
the whole Squad ride today we do need a
touchdown
they definitely do need is a touchdown
from Cordell Patterson yes
we've got a woeful woeful saying he's
been betting on each side to punt each
Drive he's up over 300 so far see this
is what I'm talking about that's next
level betting yeah it is that guy shout
out dirty birdie well that was Waffle
wolf or wolf oh my bad
waffle waffles
I I I don't I don't mean to be that guy
I don't mean to be that guy I don't know
what this guy's unit size is but I will
say the drive that the Panthers got a
field goal he would have lost money and
the punt in this game has been like
minus 160 every drive so I don't know if
I believe him that's all I had said
hey Bryson love the love the analytics
brother I love the analytics he's not
sure because sometimes people do come
into the chat and just say whatever
honestly I'm also projecting because I
have over eight and a half pawns they're
not punting enough
oh no
and Eddie Pinero
what we need honestly I think gonna cash
all his bets in the first half this is
what I honestly need is PJ Walker to
leave the game no we need an
interception oh yeah throw a pick and
then bring in Baker Mayfield because I
know the Panthers will punt eight and a
half times themselves
Hunters
through the scoop
a foreman runs hard he does he runs hard
he's not Texas right I believe so thank
you I think he lost to Kansas I really
do
2016 comes back to Kansas always
yeah he did go to town so two years in a
row catch that over yes sir drafted
third round by the Texans second quarter
guys 14 minutes left
is anybody tracking how's everybody's
bets looking not great Bryson you have
two I'm 2-0 I'm not supposed to talk
about that anymore though wait wait
you're 1-0 bro oh something that is
running hard well the squad took the
nsmt bro I am part of the squad all
right so we're all okay we're all wanna
know got you got you I am two now a
little different yeah no I'm not feeling
great because two of my bets need a
touchdown to be scored in this game so
that's like not
you're not Tracking not good what was
what did the over under close at was it
41 41 and a half oh my God
they were really giving us I'm not
feeling great about Patterson it was a
shootout in the second half last time
these two played indoors so far
that's true this is bizarre man how is
it that these games are always under
it's crazy I mean I know the short week
it's like click that less time to
prepare for when it goes over
come on man you would honestly I feel
like if you have less time to prepare
that should actually help the offense
that's what I think yeah what it really
comes down to is NFL coaches suck it's
like they they are the ones that need it
it's Ben McAdoo's fault yeah it honestly
is man like is it bro there is a tuba as
chuba I'm about to look at it
I think that
no I think that um
you drew it didn't you no uh
what's happening I don't understand
no he doesn't he has uh PJ Walker no I
have PJ Walker wait I forget now Bryce
is mixing up our bed no no let's go back
to the book let's go back let's let's
pull it back up DJ Bryson got me
confused
I love Ryan's computer there it is
Bryson those are our bets I'm talking
about what you drew out of a hat Greg
yeah that's DJ more than we'll take this
are you talking about the tick tock oh
yeah I did get how many years does
anyone know how many yards I could check
for you right now those are our bets
they're up there with that uh no Score
first drive cashed wow uh we lead
Cordell 37 now wait am I losing it yeah
Drake London that's 20. receiving yards
that's 20.
all right intersection
DJ Moore DJ Moore's kind of uh do this
thing's total better overall passing
yards DJ more has 20. I feel better
about his under still yeah that's 28
he's got 27 yards yeah but they're not
they're not throwing it that way oh yeah
but he's only throwing it to him right I
don't know what else is coming fast I
think or Chanel got one that's not
bringing it guys yeah let's just ignore
it DJ Moore has 20 I believe I think I
just said 28. yeah how you feeling about
that over I feel good I shot for the
moon on that I wanted a couple uh also
big plus money joints so I feel pretty
good you know I'm a big football guy
does anyone know what team Xavier Woods
is on because I bet his over four and a
half tackle boxes and someone DM me on
Twitter and said that was a lot so I
took it another first I think he's on
the phone so you so you blind bet at
that yeah yeah so are you gonna give
that person a cut if you don't think
you're bad no yeah yeah yeah right
that's the conversation see this is what
I'm saying because you would have never
you don't even know who he is you never
know right now why is that why is the
new DM in me locks because he's trying
to share the money thank you and I'm
gonna take the money what's the problem
greed is the root of all evil man give
him a 50 bro bro we got scripture going
but why can't that guy bet for example I
probably did why does he deserve it I
just want to clarify you just asked me
to give this one more money than I bet
and will win on this [ __ ] oh wow I
don't know your unit
I think this is just distracting us from
the fact that Ryan is like not even
considering splitting what looks like a
an eventual of course yeah
he's just gonna he's just gonna leave
well the record I'm gonna be it's gonna
be producer bowling
I'm gonna be on the Sunday show I'm
gonna need somebody find control room to
bring me a suitcase of money after that
hits I have to take you take you with a
security escort yeah you said he's on
the Falcons he's on the Panthers bro oh
is he yeah he's got two times let's go
man that's worse than the fraud who
likes to know
confidently it does it's like just be
quiet yeah no it was too quick
nobody else said anything you said it
yeah
neck out there like that
[Laughter]
I want to discuss possibly live betting
the next drive for the Falcons oh so
let's see let me see if I can get that
up here let's do it
live props what are you thinking it
might be oh no that's crazy stuff let's
play
go on your DraftKings app they got a lot
of live offerings yeah we're gonna have
a nice they got the flash setting going
no free promo
Moody baby says Panthers double double
is a lock does anybody know what that
means
what are you sure double double
I'm trying to think yeah Woody baby you
got to explain I got too many bets Moody
baby get oh
double
time yeah where did I hear that from
somebody said yeah because somebody
tried to say triple double and they put
double double and I have never heard
that in my life before
I like that that's pretty good well you
do know I'm trying to figure out what
does it mean I mean that's triple double
that's a triple doubled out yeah
this sounds like an inside joke went
right over who dropped that comment I
feel like it's like the same idea as
like NCAA you know I mean it's like yeah
they're spelling out triple double
can we also talk about how when people
say nc2a they need to shout off to the
Moon yeah it's rough so many yeah I'm
now I'm my ass is in the jackpot Moody
baby figured Ryan would pretend to know
I'm never leaving I mean
a pattern of consistent behavior that
concerning you brought this away from
yourself producer Ryan that's nobody
else wanted to answer Bryce's question I
figure I just give it a shot I
appreciate it though honestly it didn't
matter because he doesn't know who he is
anyways
I don't know if it's a false start I
look like no it's like
good call Kirk
um fall star everybody but the center I
love that guy that's a class I need a
sack here so I can get a party
lost the mic
oh they put it on one guy everybody but
the center all right I have the uh the
Falcons Drive pulled up for for next one
all right so punt is minus 135 field
goal attempt plus 380. touchdown not
happening plus 400 and then turn over or
turn over on Downs or safety is plus
650. I'm going punt I have a field goal
of 10 plus 380. yeah field goal attempt
so it doesn't have to go exactly I'll
take the turnover dude yeah I'll just
say turnover sound let's go turn over
sound kind of kind of cute yeah I mean I
think we're gonna get another eddiepie
yeah that's what I'm saying I think the
Panthers talking they were talking that
talking about that
but I was there when he was kicking
Chad kicked against eddiep okay Chad
Johnson kicked who won
Eddie eddiepie but narrow I can't I
think Chad yeah
I think it was like he made at least a
50 yarder I think it was yeah for sure
50. I think that Jeff's trying to
attempt to 60. I don't know that is not
just Saturday
Jack and kick
all right so what do we have we have a
punt
me and Bryson are on turnover
yeah yeah field goal attempt field goal
attempt Logan's field goal attempt yeah
we have to figure out what's going to
happen on this job yeah turn over turn
over on Downs plus six okay do we do we
get Phil do we think Phil go here
what is this third and long yeah yeah
eddiepie it's Eddie pieces field though
what is it I need a Grady 12.
I don't bet a lot of defensive problems
oh Inception oh
ah he's not in there this is a win-win
for me though to be honest
yeah this is gonna be long bro imagine
your editor are we putting money too
early dude twenty dollars Ryan bowling
on the field goal I got twenty dollars
on the over it possible we're gonna hit
it ten dollars on the field goal I'll
give you two dollars two dollars that's
my universe
two dollars Ryan all right two dollars
that you think he misses
I think he makes he's gonna miss don't
what are we doing the elevatory I'm out
call timeout oh so wait if they don't
even attempt to field goal do I win no
it's a void it's a void
it's in cash it that's big that's
because she's on the road somebody
walked right up to the cashier window
and they were like bro that didn't hit
he didn't even wait when did that happen
when did that I said don't celebrate
before it happens he said I'm gonna get
my Panero a little high five back here
it's tough scene oh really yeah
right
this is hard to watch I'm not gonna lie
I'm glad that they closed uh the
turnover because I don't like the
turnover anymore I like I liked the
turnover on the back of them being down
6-0 yeah I don't like a turnover here
all right stop him pin him back there oh
safety safety gonna hit bro
[Music]
for sure
if you guys at home don't know what
we're doing we had it Ryan did we lock
in everybody do we lock in our bets
we're we're taking the factors
turnover now
minus 170. turn over turn over on Downs
or safety they're pinned back deep plus
390 touchdowns plus 600 again that ain't
happening field goal 10 plus 650.
so time out 99.99 I just want to say as
a guy that loves value no offensive
score minus 400 up there
why is Fields goals
minus 400. everything I've won so far
I'm putting it on that right now I kid
you not 54.59 why is field goal a
terrible
for 23 cents go get your 14. I ain't go
a lot that might be uh that's McDonald's
so we're in the same boat no offensive
all right I'm locking in field goal
attempt right now
listen Mariota we're gonna get we're
gonna get a couple of creepy scrambles
all right I'm in field goals I need to
go first play I want to know what the
chat thinks though yeah because we need
we need the people's bets all right uh
Gator's saying punts
Jack I'm saying I got touchdown on this
jackham let's go baby let's go I don't
got a touchdown value let alone but
honestly though you're not trying to
you're not trying to spread the wolf
I can't get close enough to show the
world are we back on this this is the
first time in my life I've ever bet a
minor you're not trying to spread them
what is it no offense we all sat in that
room and we said there may not be a
touchdown
what's up man so so we we all know what
type of guy Ryan is he's not going to
help this is Everest any money of the
bet that we gave him right now this is
everyone regretting not actually placing
the BET yeah I'm like I know why he
don't want to do it
all right let's see what let's see what
no touchdown is right now
not even on the board because it's chalk
all right guys on the board yeah
everybody lock in I love that we got
this uh Falcons Drive coming up we all
got our bets I need a punch defensive
touchdown right here I'm in on field
goal attempt local got a field goal
Ben's got a field goal yeah yeah you
guys got turnover yeah and no offensive
score bowling
producer Ryan what do you have I I got
to turn over turn over on Downs or
safety
I'll take out all right
uh yeah we need him so we've got dirty
birdie with a field goal to strive
offensive score
oh dude we got a hater in the chat man
you really hate to see that
oh there are a lot of haters offensive
score offensive scores plus 285. no off
not even good though l
you're really asking them to drive 60
yards pinned on their own five man it's
a terrible bet
we're at three punts by the way
come on come on
more yards oh keep pushing all right I'm
not feeling good
yeah
he's trying to ruin us
now they're gonna throw a 60-yard pass
because you said punt was the lock
third and four yeah Mariota in a shotgun
London goes in motion that's the full
start
hand off on third and four
no no no no no
you got to go for it gotta go for it
you don't go for it on your own 12. I
got turn over oh I don't like that spot
he didn't get it and I challenge him
down
Arthur Smith that's Arthur's job if he
goes
have some guts
I have some pride hey Ryan the good news
is that was fun you're nine yards I'll
take it
Rome was the middle of the day no 41 and
a half yeah over 31 and a half we may
not lose tonight it's a put Bryson or
safety give me a state wait safely alive
that'd be crazy that would have been
yeah I forgot I had a mic pack on
Falcons are plus four uh oh the live
money yeah you're cooked brother uh
money line is plus 155 uh if you want to
take the Panthers money line at this
point it's chalk uh and the live total
is 30. up it went off the board that
means somebody's here oh oh how are you
good value for me maybe that means the
turnover is coming
could it be you guys did win your bet
and also we did I would just like to say
that we were in the room earlier and we
talked about a plus 9000 play that you
could have put five dollars on but you
chose to place a minus 400 bet because
everything changed when the balls kicked
off yeah The Vibes changed Ron wasn't
built the day also I wasn't in the room
for that or else I would have definitely
bet it I think I was in the bathroom or
something all right that's gonna give me
an excuse Greg I think that's a
convenient excuse yeah whatever man
I don't mind I think I remember I think
I remember that's all
all I know is that if somebody told me
about a bet that I wasn't going to place
any cash I would give them a little cut
I I want to say for the record too that
I was in the bathroom when like the
actual bet was placed so when I left
there was still deliberation that's more
money so like that's even right now let
me find out you actually place the BET
until we were here what this is all
translating to is oh my God Ryan you
placed such a good bet and I wish I did
the same well you see the thing is Right
Logan knows
definition
my honest day here Ryan if you showed me
you putting 11 bucks on it and
submitting you like that one's almost a
grand I was like hello and the thing is
you were the only person who knew I had
no money left in my DraftKings account
because I had to have you place another
bet for me so therefore I feel like you
should know that I wanted to ride with
you and that part of that 11 bet was me
that's just my do you think it was my
responsibility to ask
I think it's like we got a lot of
flip-flopping going we got social
networked by Ryan yeah we had a great
idea and he took it once again
over here
that's who we got dude yeah this is
unreal
where is that breathing the Winkle of
Austin
yeah the Winkle Boss Brian is uh we got
a bunch of dogs that bark and we've got
one dog that bites Brian I thought I
thought there was a mutual understanding
if it lost I was 100 on you but I guess
so we don't so listen it was a terrible
punt they could score a touchdown right
here what's the flash odds for no
offensive score I think I'm gonna Hammer
this again I won't get in that way uh no
offensive scores minus 165. now here
comes we're behind Okay yeah we are yeah
yeah I don't like that
oh no big ball play action anyone but DJ
yeah we love good tackle Grant
um Xavier Woods Char Charlie Mains upset
at Arthur Smith he said fourth an inches
and a punt wow that's what I said have
some guts oh my god dude how do you
trust the guy who wearing a NASCAR had a
football game how do you trust him they
know that and he chased his hat
good for him now you got to trust him
now I trust him dude now you trust him
he's got the NASCAR hat on why you gotta
do the goofy stuff man just where you
got a box full of stuff to wear wear
your stugs yeah Falcons logos dope
fire just wear it Joe Gibbs Racing look
uh Greg can I get a Time update
four minutes of 45 dude this is
hit him hit him in the backfield I love
that I love that oh
yeah
baby let's go what's that pick that name
out of a hat baby oh through your dance
bro
those Falcons are just ran into each
other bro
there's the replay oh Ryan oh Ryan
[Applause]
that's a run a run flips like that all
of a sudden everyone ran into each other
I hope that was obviously we're gonna
score a touchdown 100 that's great
blocking that's all right yeah that was
a run
watch this watch this run how do you run
into each other uh eddiep I don't care
what you do here man wait that's a run
I'm feeling great about that was
backwards 100 right now I don't know how
you could ever like go back to your
other helmets after this game they
caught it a run this is like a permanent
change we're just gonna completely yeah
low top jigs
I just said to you like two minutes ago
that if it lost we were I was in no part
I got lost so I moved operator in the
chat shout me out thank you weatherman
Mike Steve yeah Logan very happy for you
I just I feel like we're ignoring just
took place so now I should pay all of
you who gave me the best right yes
that's what someone with class would do
yeah you know we're very classy not all
of us have you know it's something
you're born with it's true I did listen
Vince is a Yankees fan so he doesn't
like spending money right that's the
thing wow shots fired
Brian you don't want to start it just
beating beating me while we're done
I've got no more fight left in me
where's the ground going
come on
the chat has not giving me any degrom
face it's been too much smoke there he's
going to the Braves
Braves stop it it's happening no he's
going for the money goes to the Braves
while we're live I'm going home
you don't think he's leaving the Mets
nah
yeah yeah they should no don't don't
give them fall so
he's smiling I mean if the Cubs want to
play anyway damn bro who got you smiling
like that here's the thing here's the
thing TD my computer one I'm sure that
paid pretty good yeah especially yeah
what was that first touchdown I can't
remember what the first time I don't
know where's uh it's pretty solid
otd for sure yeah and honestly he
they've been trying to figure out how to
use him for a long time
in the league like he's bounced around
he was really we were talking about he
was really good college in Colorado yeah
the names and put them in the Hat where
I did pick
channels for first time maybe that's the
one correct me if I'm wrong Logan was
last to pick right I will was that last
illusion uh
you one could argue Logan knows all of
us money here because we picked other
names out so we had a better chance oh
we narrowed it down for him I like that
logic just saying I would like that
I'll take ten that track's out I mean we
just don't include Ryan because he
wasn't going to include us right so like
that limits the you know what I mean and
you saw he tried to flip right away he
tried to flip on I would just like
address your nonsense my nonsense was
addressed for the entire history he
wasn't even in the end zone yet before
Ryan was already yeah and everyone you
see everyone how focused they were on
the game it's like I wasn't even here uh
Mike Steve Ritter saying uh Chenault was
30-1 for first t-day that's pretty good
hey uh can we get Cordell Patterson
going yeah we do need it for the most
part we need the Falcons in general to
get going they look like they stayed on
the bus no yeah they're not really even
they look like they're warming up the
bus also I I torched Jack a good place
to play call so they really didn't call
it a pass huh for the passing that's
what I'm saying I did I did torch Jack
in the first pass out on that drive and
imagine that running into each other no
it was that one oh this is Archer Smith
on the hot seat what do you guys think
yeah yeah nullify my take
London not open yo throw the ball it's
wide open right there he's wide open
right there that's a oh across the field
that's a hold
on
that's awesome always a really good idea
to throw the ball across the field like
that at the end that's like Marcus
married yeah right with the big arms
no way okay nose oh it was bird again I
was that Zacchaeus or whatever
he holds the ball like uh like a top man
gotta go run and get the ball hey four
minutes left guys second quarter
this is cash a BET right yeah I had
Chanel Junior FIRST TD baby
hold
don't matter oh my God yes it doesn't
matter hey second half that means
cordell's Patterson's gonna get the ball
a lot because they're going to be down
but he don't catch pass that's how we
have to think that's that's the vibe we
need it's the vibe we need but I don't
know anything about the coaching staff
in Atlanta I'm not really inspired
and he can't make the play happen that's
better even the grip yeah that's what
I'm saying like a toddler looking right
now he holds in the middle of the boat
no foul how do you pick up an offensive
holding call though in all honesty how
do you do that oh then you saw it you
saw it you can't like
that's unreal we've got a Chad in the
chat asking us what we got in on so well
sir I have the Falcons and I'm gonna try
and capture should we pull up the board
yeah we've got uh we've got a little
handy-dandy spreadsheet right should I
cash out for 13 bucks
fifty dollars 28 yards does anyone here
who's like you're cashing out oh it's
now 11. who's like really primed on this
drive for something
uh I could use a young way or a Grady
Jarrett sack that'd be fun okay and I
could use an Eddie Panera field goal so
there we go both can happen yeah both
can happen it literally just took away
all the passing yards out on the Falcons
I could use a couple tackles
essentially bad for The Vibes
the more that the Panthers because the
happier I will be if you're in the chat
and you bet on Drake London send us an
emoji with yourself they're not a pass
first offense
it's terrible even in games you're like
a trailing like
they will run
and uh
and yeah they don't ditch the running
more often it's kind of like our Jets
and Giants huh
a little bit
but yeah it's I would love a stagnant
for these weapons here all right guys
can we get PJ Walker's first career
we got to do run or pass I'm in
but the crazy thing is
tournaments this is
this game is exactly like we probably
all expected
but we had this hope
and now it's like we all should have
just put everything we own on the under
yeah yeah I hate thinking like that but
it's like
I just like got too smart I think yeah I
mean I definitely didn't get too smart I
mean my IQ is too loud that's the
problem
oh oh no I think that's what I'm gonna
start saying all right guys here we go
tournament style all right I'm going
past over one Vince Vince and Michael
Bolin first I'm going past this is a run
going past two minutes and 30 seconds
left play action on that own dial up
Tommy Trump actually ball is on the
Falcons what
they got 35. oh my God First and Ten
yeah it is a run who won that one Vince
bowling is out [ __ ] he moves on I'm
eliminated Bryson Logan from everything
two minute warning time me me again but
I'm gonna grind well I'm gonna run was
also like minus 500. yeah yeah that was
yeah it's a good reference
I mean yeah you know he's a betting man
tell me I won't BET next let's play Run
you won't
interesting stuff here wow what a game
man love this I love The Vibes in here
though
high energy shootout you know Carolina
ew the Falcons are plus 11 live right
okay I gotta get that they're plus 500.
why would you not wait till the end of
this Drive Bowling
yeah that's true I would probably
because here comes the turn plus 11 and
a half on DraftKings right now plus 500
on the fumble recovery for a touchdown
awesome dude how do I how do I bet the
next play and then over under is 35
minutes
here in the flash yeah I don't know you
might not be able to do next play you
have to wait you maybe have to wait till
the next what about what about next
player to catch a pass oh interesting
that's pretty good is that up uh but
it's for the Falcons next round yeah
it's for the Falcons uh but they don't
throw either I mean mariota's throwing
to the Panthers no I don't can you can
you do interception next time everybody
said I think the other day we could find
the other team yeah but this will be for
whenever whenever they ask I said a fake
the ankle injury in the uh when I was
supposed to kick against eddiep now did
that happen
it did hurt my ankle but how do they
even know that that was a long time ago
I don't even know how I hurt myself the
line's here but it's down bro fourth God
fifth play attempt this is good vibes
from Mr ding great game I hope both
teams win awesome yeah yeah so by that
logic we would end in a tie
yeah
because you don't win or lose well he
wants both teams to win we got I need Mr
the bare minimum says Marcus Mariota is
the goat
cite your sources yeah Mr Dingman
somebody said guys don't fall asleep do
not worry we're not dude I got I'm
castied up don't you worry about that
Ryan's got his kick in a king I might
honestly lucky I ain't on that couch
I might go to sleep on this game all
right so now might be a good time to be
honest before the game honestly
go ahead I'm sorry I didn't mean to
touch you no no you're bailing me out I
was gonna get yelled out again I'm damn
near ready to bet
every series of the second half
and damn near bet punt every series yeah
I mean that's what this guy I forget who
said it in here but somebody did say
that they were up 300 just by doing that
every single Drive
if they bet every series on the on the
on the Falcons punt in Houston Houston
white is asking who is doing the best so
far I think that's Bryson but he also
placed more bets than anyone come on
yeah
I mean if we want to be fair
mathematically Bryson had a better
chance to be better than everyone yeah
it's not a balanced uh playing field I
also have more training Saloon the only
one that's risking that much at the same
time so like who's won the most money so
far Bryson you're the only one who's
cashed a BET right yeah well everybody
we all cast no Score first drops good
point good point effectively shout out
to our friends at DraftKings was free
money yep shout out to the homies
because that was literally the easiest
bet I've cashed in months yeah that was
uh I also want to say that I wanted to
bet Run next play didn't get to him all
right all right yeah let's get back into
that my bad my bad bowling got knocked
off by my man Vince we're doing
tournaments now run or pass Bryson is up
against bagel and locks My Man Logan how
are we doing what are we doing guys what
do you want 37 dang we missed two not
running the ball here yes they are
you're going run yes Bryson's going run
he thinks that they're going oh it's
gonna be a scream
let's go
Bryson moves on and this is the funniest
game ever dude
Vince is alive Bryson is alive me and
Ryan are alive but we're going to wait
to the next Drive Eddie p is on
it good thing he's never missed the
field Ryan has a bet on this kick right
here I will say this if he makes this
I'll give Vince 20.
no because Vince wants a portion of
every bet that I will listen I'll I'll
take it if you're if you're throwing the
offer and we take it that we're taking
it and we're you know I bet it on the
next round oh imagine they cut and
they're going for it how much time's
left uh Greg one minute and 52 seconds
all right plenty of time wait wait
record for it right do we have that pits
catch next Drive bet is that possible uh
okay I think it still is yeah all right
man yeah 100 okay here it is
another opportunity
it's weird because like 49 yards you
don't like the left hash don't uh-oh the
snack the kick is up it's right yeah
I got some money there let's go there it
is baby
what are we doing I just love seeing my
friends
Falcons first place pass minus 425.
Falcons first play pass minus 425. pass
yeah
that's pretty good there's no yeah
there's no way they just phoned it out
we're gonna try to score without a doubt
so here's Logan I don't feel great about
it but I'm tempted yeah I'm tempted I
mean I
I don't know what's up Ryan we have a
comment for you uh Miller time in MN I'm
assuming that MN is for Minnesota yeah
who was the guy in the Hat Logan is our
so introduce yourself he wants to know
who you are and if you do the guy in the
Hat he looks what I want to hear his
allegations he looks bored yeah I want
to hear his allegations and then Houston
white said he does look bored all right
I'm betting the back end over here
should I get in with you bro can I win
one bet today first okay it's the first
play of this drive all in bro let's go
yo the first one right in front of my
face no that means I'm gonna lose all by
myself no if this hits I'm gonna be so
sorry you have passed right now bowling
no no I said first player the drive will
be a first down yeah I love that what
are those odds plus 245. easy underneath
route pits right here
yup yup look right there yep let's go
yeah it's good it's good dude I wanted
that so bad boy no I'm back
right there it's another twenty dollars
in a way you're gonna get some of this
one
true personally I had another 15. let's
go I'm not casting out Falcons they're
gonna come back and win the game we do
and uh so we have Tyler Mallett in the
chat asking us what some good bets for
the second half hold your horses we will
get there once we get to halftime uh Jad
saying he didn't know that somebody even
came up with a nickname for Eddie Pinero
Eddie Money any money eddiepie eddiepie
pushing eddiepie please
we have many nicknames for any Panera
it's too easy yeah
shout out DraftKings they put the money
in the account quick bro
oh yeah oh certainly that's Huntley we
don't like that yo to get him to the
bench little urgency
what are we looking at with power here
we go run pass here me you Ryan run past
I'm going to take a shot I'm going past
yeah pass gotta go Ryan yeah
could you imagine if it's a run we could
just push until you guys will both be
outside yeah
there we go Greg we're moving on
he just saved him from another pick
right
right man you got to get out of bounds
run pass pass
yeah yeah I mean if anyone that's run
the rest of this drive that's just like
that's on you only on the only on the
goal line if Marcus Mariota scrambles
that is a run yeah I just
oh my God oh my God oh my God oh my God
it's not outside is it no it's hot it's
rigged
another one I heard it that means Vince
moves on it's just me and Vince
[Music]
that's the young way that's the young
way Young
whoo Court dude it's so funny that like
people really like is it Arthur Arthur
Smith yeah yeah
these are some crazy calls and they're
working
like he's just outsmart like is that
smart or is he just like zigging when
people zag and I've never heard of
Williams but like
you call a run on second and four and
you died they don't abandon the Run
okay there's Cordero Patterson Jacob
asked the same thing
we don't have any timeouts though why
are you in the bank
how much time is left
20 seconds
foreign
[Music]
he had space at the end of the day we
always come back to Young way
and that's where we are if he misses
this I'm gonna cry oh my God I want to
like toss my phone
um guys I have a question I mean this is
blocky bathroom what do they do
take the mic off yeah asking for a
friend obviously exactly my friend is
asking me
wait what did you say I said my friend
needs to go bathroom they were asking me
they just take the mic off or what the
situation is
just go the uh yeah
yeah you you know you can turn your mic
off did not know that it's a good it's a
good update I think you will have help
when you do if you have to
we have we're good for now we're gonna
have a second
[Laughter]
oh my God
yeah this is we're live Bryson yeah I
hope you know
this is not content I don't know how to
produce this you taking your mic off is
not conscious We're Not Gonna post that
yeah
we could though take it take it with you
we always could over under 30 and a half
seconds for him to get out of here oh is
he good no that's gonna be easy all
right and that makes sense
get out of here get out of here
it's great shout out to Bryson we're
live we're a nightmare yeah we're live
in uh all right what we got
we're gonna do this without without
Bryson he's in timeout for a little bit
uh but Tyler Mallett jumped in here
before uh while this the first episode
going on and asked us what we like for
the second half so I want to talk a
little bit about the second half but I
also kind of want to talk about Sunday
because this game's trash yeah this game
is trash so like can we we gotta get
ahead of it before we talk about Sunday
we should remind everyone that
DraftKings is giving out a flash bet at
halftime 50 profit boost
that's a good point so if you're trying
to get on something live let us know in
the chat we're taking something live
during this halftime break that's a good
point 50 profit boost and I'm kind of
hot on the live bets he is he is
he's already got about this game
and I hit a minus four we need like a
bet tracker
or something like that you know what I
mean because a lot of people was like
saying what they got and then Bryson
comes out of left I want to talk about
him but we gotta Left Field hold up says
that he has bets so let's let's bring up
the spreadsheet one more time before
we're all over the place right now we'll
go we'll go to the spreadsheet and then
let's talk second half bets okay so here
we go Bryson has cash first field goal
before 14 minutes elapsed I mean what a
wild pet crazy how he got there I don't
know uh no offensive score on Atlanta's
third brother shouldn't even be up there
that's minus 400 like cast that also
live yes okay I mean you did it live
that's respect but uh I have cash by
Eddie Pinero over one and a half field
goals made and again we cash as a squad
on the no Score first drive wait so
that's huge is minus 400 that's
questionable no it's free money I got it
free money yeah it's a free seven bucks
I put 30 bucks on it wait wait Bryson
had seven picks earlier now he has well
we added the live bet yeah
we don't have to add mine
yeah okay so maybe we go away from the
spreadsheet you know we get done with
the spreadsheet you'll go outside all
right let's discuss what we're using our
friends
okay so don't pull that expression I see
Ritter in the chest plus eight live I
kind of like that because that would be
us wait we're gonna say Falcons Falcons
plus eight live no I like that it's
Ritter right I like that Ritter yeah
Ritter they look good on that last Drive
Ritter also said Bryson's a disaster
retweet yes 100 and we gotta tell him
when he comes back let's talk about that
they look good in the last drive we know
that Carolina's gonna run the ball yes
in the second half I love this okay
don't and I want more takes from the
chat but
it's a 50 profit boost and right now
they're live money line on DraftKings if
we can hit it is plus 340. on the
Falcons on the Falcons don't do it I'll
take those I'll take this I mean I'm
personally already in on the money line
oh you'd be doubling yeah I'm in on the
money line too and I'm saying don't do
it that bet that BET's trash and we're
gonna get some Cordell Cordell Patterson
like get them going yeah I don't know I
like that money line Ryan and then maybe
some Desmond Ritter in the second huh so
Marcus Mariota live unders
yeah okay so I want Vince to know before
I do it is
and it'll be a 50 profit boost so it'll
be juicy so yeah I don't want to touch
that
until they start storming back
um
I just went to the bathroom and you're
bringing back more water yeah it's back
from time out hydrated die back from
time out uh Bryson uh Ritter jumped in
the chat called you a disaster he wasn't
wrong either how many bets is Ritter hit
tonight
wait Bryson hey can we pull back up
we're halftime here so we're chilling
we're talking second half bets but
Bryson there's some controversy going on
with your uh your bets bro wow yeah
let's go I submitted them all last night
you submitted them last night you
started the show with seven bets now
there's eight okay because we got in on
that live yeah and it says there live
and for the record I was the only one
that was like I'll ride with you Bryson
yeah because we made money are we really
cashing off minus 400 like because last
time DraftKings let's you have an
account let's you have an account you
have an account now we're playing this
game now we're playing this game also
secondly just one so for you by the way
boy bowling cash first play first down
last Drive I need to see that up so
where's my where's my pie where's my bed
I don't know bro you talked to max hand
up hand up hand up we got some takes in
the chat going on here Poe dazzo saying
Falcons will ball in the second half
lock it in and then we've got Kay
Barbosa second half over 20. oh over
it's Kane Brown Kane Brown Kane Brown
yeah interesting that's been Ritter
though that works too
I win
okay
wait what do we so what are we I'm gonna
tell you guys what I planned about one
drive at the end of the half is
fascinating to me I think it's Fool's
Gold what have you done for me lately
Vince I'm fading now Hey listen my live
halftime bet with my 50 profit boost
will beat wait Dante Foreman to score
the next touchdown
and when I use the profit boost it goes
from plus 650 to Plus 9.75.
locking that in down to Foreman Deontay
Foreman can't see it because my
brightness second half over 20. what do
you guys think about that like that a
lot of points like that three teddies
three teddies next year no idea oh let
me get I mean the weather is watch the
first half yeah
but where were you guys last time they
played guys they had a uh that's true we
saw a shootout shootout in the second
half it also was indoors and it wasn't
definitely was indoors and the elements
was not playing a factor but we're only
talking 20 points
the real question is the wind hasn't
changed why didn't I grab falcons live
when they're down 13-0 you told me to
wait I told you to wait at 10-0 oh lose
the attitude sir no we're the we're the
best yes how do I get this the live
Boost though is that where you went what
the Falcons plus eight live
I like that one oh if you just go to NFL
it'll be right up there get a 50 profit
boost to flash about the Falcons versus
Panthers game
I'm in there like swimwear yes sir
oh can I win this next hundred bucks did
you just burp no I said okay oh also if
I did what don't burp into your
microphone yeah
[Laughter]
okay
okay I want everybody to see it so maybe
it'll go on the on the screen I need
more takes from the I need somebody to
talk me into a bet took okay I'm talking
you into a BET right now oh he's
pitching oh Michael Ritter
no you're telling me Ritter's bad yeah
that's a lock what is it no seven and a
half now but we we he said it at eight
seven and a half now
the Falcons they look good in that last
Drive
plain and simple I'm not jumped off the
boat I couldn't cash out because they
suspended it so so Brian
they just jumped up to plus eight They
Ride The Point gotta get in there I'll
take the points I just took the points
but when they win this is this is going
to be the Callback to like moments that
preceded disaster yeah exactly yeah
I'm saying um I'm seeing it through you
guys at home we're riding with Michael
Ritter we saw them the last Drive of the
third quarter we saw how they moved the
ball guys we know that the Carolina
Panthers are going to come out running
the ball
take the points all right I know what
I'm doing uh Moody baby saying fade
Ritter all of it on Falcons normally I
would do the same but I'm riding with it
I took Falcons I can't so I don't want
to be that guy like he's not doing this
intentionally he said fade rarer than
the next thing he said was ATL money
long that's it this is this is gone out
of control okay Panthers minus seven and
a half using my Boost doubling down on
the pattern 100 right away this is way
too much momentum and favoritism with
the fat with with the Falcons everyone
is talking themselves into it I have to
be the voice of reasons put my name
behind it that's it we're locked in
so Vince wants money from everyone's
winning bet and then Fades everyone
so you're in a you're not you're in a
win-win situation no no I'm the only one
using logic right now so I will that's a
way to put it he spread the love okay so
I know your birthday tomorrow but geez
maybe maybe that's playing into it a
little bit but yeah I can't I can't sit
here and stay silent anymore
okay it's for the record out of control
Bryson and I are in on another live bet
is it minus 400 no it's minus 165. okay
I like love the record show I use the
Boost at DraftKings it's minus 111 for
me
oh minus 111 for you very good I'm on
Dante Foreman punt next Drive punt first
drive of the second four men to score
the next touchdown
so just like the next touchdown period
so it's basically like first touchdown
score for the second half and it's a
minus what no it was plus 650 I got it
with my profit boost it's plus 9.75.
okay so I'm going for I'm going for the
jugular so I get all these bets back
that I'm gonna lose otherwise except for
a young way yeah I feel it your Chase
end of the day it's always young way all
right your Chase what's up
Chase with you 3 30. do we I see three I
bet Eddie p
oh you could do live what are we live
better net EP okay so I'm gonna be
pushing B hold on so so everyone can see
so everyone can win
some people on this set have problems
with all right if we don't share the
wealth
it's not everyone it's just some okay
Eddie P right here let's see it
over 10 and a half kicking points right
now he has
seven oh boy it's tough all right that's
a field goal on an extra point oh okay
that's kind of a lot young way though
over five and a half oh it needs another
field goal yeah but right now they're
down 10. so are you are you in the field
goal kicking mood I like that well yeah
I like within a touchdown at least so I
I actually hey that's pretty I like that
young way young way older way yo I'm
hurting the Falcon stream though we're
riding right now I'm way over
brother over five over five and a half
uh kicking he's at three he's at three
right now just need one more field if
they have to
because they're down ten they might kick
a field goal this first who gets the
ball and we need to stop if they make a
stop then Atlanta's in the it's a big
field goal kicking mood they're only
down too yeah that's not a lot locked
because everybody wrote but it's quick
man we speak everybody's taking it
immediately
yeah Eddie's too much I'm letting the
Falcon stream know we're riding I love I
love me some eddiep but I already won me
some money from eddiepie I agree it is
too much young way young way over 5.5 I
think he gets cash this is basically you
double it down yes and it's plus money I
think it was five and a half before the
game started too it won't lie but
uh oh also I meant to say before I was
gonna get me in trouble but uh I did
place before the show uh race to 25
points
um not neither neither of us neither
right yeah all of us have that right
yeah yeah 19 or 13. yeah neither team to
get 25 points and that was plus 115. oh
hell so you want to tell us after the
game started
cool
thanks
if you see I'm allowing you to keep it
you'll be an eye guy right I'm not being
an I wanted to own up to it so when
Bryce and I are celebrating and I have
my suitcasian suitcase of cash DST yes
you guys understand why yeah oh that was
a bad kick awesome perfect
wait so we got Bryson and Vince right we
got you guys that was yeah because we
both uh run run past here we go
Championship Round Here
this is a run yeah so nobody but me grab
Falcons ml huh
let's go baby let's go you know who did
work didn't
everyone's points I'm on the points
Ryan's on the point so wait official
announcement for our halftime live bet
so everyone knows it is Falcons plus
seven and a half that's the majority
that's what we took from the chat it's
Falcons plus seven and a half let's go
lesson plus eight if you dare to be
better
I got it at plus
seven and a half hours
fifty percent fifty percent boost come
on
hopefully you guys lost
the fumble that's a fumble it's 100
fumble and Cornell oh that's a flag no
way yeah that was lucky oh that's huge
that was late
we're back we're back that was late
right after the announcement let's go
tack it on
oh that's a football move
oh yeah one foot that's not a couch and
complete and complete and complete and
complete and complete bro what we need
the live pump I got a live punt bro okay
okay that's a football Moon I don't know
I'm not gonna lie after he made control
I don't know
15 yards though 15 yards
this is perfect this is so good
dude live betting is easy why do people
not do that why are people bet before
the game is so easy I've never been in
four game again until tomorrow
comments that precede disaster all right
listen we got to mark it down
later on like Jim knows he can't do that
this was the best possible thing that
could have happened on that first play
no that is
still would have been a first down yeah
yeah other time this is amazing
now this is good for your scenario to
run it here too run it and gain one yard
please
[Laughter]
PG Walkers the things come on Phillip
there we go Phillip good handoff yo I
almost bet form in first rush over three
and a half but uh that would have worked
felt felt a little bit too out of pocket
just gun shy it's all good I'm so
nervous about a punt right now hey we're
good though I like the Falcons they got
a lot of momentum we all better
yeah
I know it's like I'm nervous Panthers
cover so hey hey relax Ryan we'll be
good brother I'm a nervous wrecker You
Got to Believe In The Good Vibes
I got it at eight Ryan got it at eight
Ritter had it at eight you guys probably
got a seven and a half we are pretty
that is what we are riding uh my man
Logan back there he has Falcons money
line so hopefully live Falcons money
line
Logan Falcons money line live yes we
have Squad
full effect uh Bryson did you get in on
the Falcons I'm trying to with my
winnings from this punt right now
well let us know when you lost soon as
they're back in the account we got some
good vibes for Patterson Humphrey saying
he's on the live rushing yards over of
20. oh I like that what is it live
rushing yards okay 20. Patterson for
Cordell Patterson I'm sorry yeah
if you were the head coach if you were
the head coach of the Atlanta Falcons
I'm not going to say yes and not know
and you look at your depth chart and
yeah I mean everybody's name and then
you'll see Cordell Patterson how do you
not use him more tonight I think he's
got to be banged up I said yes to nine
and six by the way just so I mean
oh
I got Panthers oh boy I almost broke one
I got Falcons oh Cordell
how don't he go over seven yards on that
catch I can't believe that because
that's probably like the only yeah oh
it's raining raining now yeah but this
is good this is good for the rest not
good for him I'm being called pets man
over 20 like 20 others in the second
half per game
uh we've got interesting we've got Mac
and I Atlanta money line plus 225
immediately followed up by Jamie giant
that's charity uh
get him oh
he's gonna run
good for the parlay oh yes
or the flag
that's got to be it is it coming back
other way oh no it has to be coming back
yeah it is
wait that was a punt though punt number
five I believe
for those keeping track at home that was
defensive holding add another 10. flag
on the play this should count as a
reception I want to play we're gonna see
what it is what is it guys
hold it
yeah
wow
the falcones baby Vince that's that's
for us oh yeah you're right
all right all right listen all right MJ
chilling wants to know do we think
Patterson's going over 55
probably the way it's yeah but I I still
have but we have hope we
we have hope but by the way it's looking
right now honestly no
55 rushing yards right yeah it's almost
young way time next dude I just took
this drive to go over the 50 and I
didn't do it
Mao saying next player to catch a pass
on the path go CP go hold on oh get
loose oh he got tripped up at the end
again sniper once we lost the shoe get
him going get him go also that was 20.
you lose weight Patterson
no gloves in the rain absolute G dude
didn't someone say live no it's had 18
yards already yeah 18 yards I need like
65.
it's not looking good what was he for
the same again parlay 49. no he wasn't
in it no he wasn't in it it was uh
London and did you get my parlayism come
on
anyone betting if he falls at the one no
look at all this rain Could Happen yeah
definitely that sounds like a scoop
maybe scoop
yes sir
yes sir yeah yeah I mean I know we held
him he called it
uh Mal's in the chat next player to
catch a pass on the Panthers any other
player at plus 475 it's Tommy tremble
time oh okay Tommy trembled shout out
our community Captain Mal our guys Mal's
got the scoobs you already know
yeah I mean I was
that was a song oh he's really he's
loving Thomas never talks about this but
like as a ref you're just like standing
in the rain I'm not even playing you're
moving you're moving
too
no no I need young waves young way yeah
so it's holding Greg holding his bad
vibes yeah that's terrible boss I'm just
confirming oh those were bat Vibes
holding his terrible vibes
there's a difference swearing on TV man
don't do that children are watching this
family show Amazon Prime they are
drenched it is yeah it's bad it's coming
down
come on come on all right weather
weather report I'm going to the weather
yeah let's go let's go back to running
our weather man what are we thinking it
is 62 degrees in Charlotte with
11 mile an hour winds still blowing west
southwest
feels like 62.
can we get a young way field goal like
not a far one
pitch
London on the track right another hold
wow
could you imagine this so wait the
announcer said it should have been
second and 11 but it was second and 13.
they ran the play and now it's another
flag what's going on the Vegas call
baby
no foul okay here we go that's Vegas
honest question they're picking them up
honest question have you guys seen this
many flags picked up in one game no
that's what I was about to say a lot of
pickup where was the line on that
Flags picked up
third and nine
they messed up on the spot
I think they get it here
I'm going to call it conversion not
because I think it's going to happen
because I need it to happen I need a
sack the offense stall I need the
conversions
that's it that's it that's it that's it
that's it that's it that's it yes yes
yes
I do like that dance though
let's go
uh seven I got a worst number than you
guys
but pot for the safety because what I
also need I want to see Desmond Ritter I
need that right Desmond ready I need
this to get off the number that it's on
right now because I have Falcons to win
by one through six and the Panthers to
cover parlayed oh yes let's do it let's
do safety right now safety right now
I'll take it I'm taking the plus 400 or
minus 400. uh Raiders already Patterson
LED them the whole Drive they take them
outer's already calling defeat he says
Falcons think I was wrong
yes that's the good result I like that
they need to unleash Cordell Patterson
that that last Drive was uh
yeah do a punt this minus 205. like a
turnover though you know it's like the
valley 600 all right I'm in we've won
enough what's the price it's plus 600.
uh Panthers six Drive result
dude
is minus 205. yeah what's no offensive
score minus 390 bro that's value
I'm back in are you in 113 on I do
literally just did it man let's go all
my money's tied up all right I haven't
won a bet a bet yet uh well that's not
true so like 70.
I'm betting I'm Punk right now uh Jamie
Germany and the under will cash so like
I'm Not Afraid when that guy fumbled
but instead it was an incomplete pass
because I remember we have a Jamie Giant
in the chat saying let's take plus 330
on the worst team in a hurricane making
making fun of us yeah that that was me
that yeah the guy the guy who looks
bored in the back yeah that's the guy in
the back
the guy on the couch uh jermez saying
these guys need to join the Marine Corps
WTF I don't know if what's he referred
players no no I just wanted to be clear
this body is not made for the military I
am not a military man I can't do that so
I hope he's talking about Falcons
okay
boy how much you put on that uh
about 113 man I hate everything about
myself I put everything I've won tonight
on it this is how you get rich man
he's not wrong he's Break by break
playing Foundation yeah it's true
this leader Sam always say load the
wagons yeah don't worry about the mules
No No's like minus 140. you're back
there chucking Waters dude I gotta stay
hydrated
how do you not take advantage of a
turnover better than that anyway no
offensive score minus 390
away
kickflip kid 20 in the chat minus 400 on
no offensive score yes sir let's go live
and direct
dude give me a safety here like just
ASAP they're gonna sneak I'd be like
right it looks kind of like it
he moved early back him up
safety
cool bowling dude boy I'm gonna be
honest with you bro I'm gonna cry if
they give us safety here because we
could have been on it that's all right
it's still a win it would still be a win
here we go are they gonna get a safety
live betting I've ever done in my life
yeah same I don't right-handed God I'm
super super happy I have no more money
left in the account so oh
all right
if this is holding in the end zone
oh
oh my god oh no it wants to throw it up
no you don't take it here
you don't accept this penalty because
dude there are if this was in the end
zone they wouldn't be asking yeah that's
a that's true yeah like he's asking if
he wants well this is hold on this is
Arthur Smith don't assume that's it's a
good point yeah
we'll just hold that
oh dude wow that was only eight inch
yard line bro he started holding maybe
you do take this just so you back them
up again there's the hole Yeah
that's a red card to be honest yeah
comes back in here saying safety on this
drive
they accepted it
they declined it I could call good call
Great call Bryson I should honestly be a
coach yeah get a headset on you like
I've we've been live betting what play
was the next one dude I'm good at this
to be honest Bryson's seeing it well
does anyone does anybody know how many
punts there have been let me I can check
I can check
and then can you just see people how
many receptions Kyle Pitts has
yeah I need you to stop bro
okay
stop my downfall bro I I bet the other
side
the field goal in the first 1359 was my
hammer
pulling oh
by the way Vince Vince got burnt right
here
we got no offensive score for fun dude
neither of these teams are getting it's
a lot of points by the way yeah
right too soon bro there it is
what we love to see Falcons money line
man Hey listen one thing you can do in a
game as miserable as this is when it's
just read the trend yep read The Room
everybody in the first half we were
super excited our balloons were deflated
and now we are betting for nothing and
we yeah it's really marvelous all of us
all of us baby let's go every single one
of us is winning back right now right
this world I guess you can't call them
kids for all you adults at home you
don't have to bet plus money all the
time it's not worth it get your money
Brick by Brick let's go
oh not the roughing one no roughing
right yeah I don't think so we're good
young way young way go go go go go what
are you doing man I don't know we're
good we're working we're chilling we're
chilling I'm glad
it's okay Greg this is
yep yep money line for show
um
that was so close our Falcons and he
didn't hit him oh wow that's wild you
can hit him I was good at athleticism
yeah that was impressive you know
kicker's got to take the hit to make the
play there now yeah
you got something what we got no I was
just about to recap our bed yeah let's
get it well not not don't bring no I
mean we can bring up the sheet but we
got other stuff you're upset about it
yeah we don't need this
but nobody else live bets are on the
sheet but Bryson's so they just know
they're gonna win Greg here we go here
we go yeah
punt is Plus 550.
but what do they know on the 45-yard
line dog oh true since you're the one
who's got the most best field goal how
are you feeling about the remaining
uh here's my take carpet's dead
yeah it was a good game good game punts
is that seven punches that um yeah so
you're yeah Panthers plus three lock
Falcons win by one through six that that
pick is sleeping and first field already
hit that Xavier Woods I got an update I
gotta check out my boy Xavier Woods real
quick sorry listen
we need Cordell Patterson to score a
touchdown
yeah Hey where's Max cashed already
let's go what Xavier Woods he's got six
hey that guy that gave you the BET
Xavier wood oh man the most famous
Carolina Panther we've never said
otherwise
no score on the drive because I've done
it twice I think I'm doing field goal
attempt for this drive what's the odds
plus 150. let's do it all right all of
it yeah no not all of it and then where
you can do what you were crossed out so
wait how is everyone else feeling about
their bets bowling uh Kyle pets is a
good game still got a chance well no
it's dead but okay all right well but
everything else that proceeded I know
Brady Jared I still have a chance young
Wayne's gonna get his field goal now I
just bet live field goal oh uh Vince we
both already won on the other it doesn't
even have to be a few block you don't
even have to make it 31 and attempt yeah
but now it's plus 199. all right here we
go I'm assuming we're going to lose
yards on this point this is not good no
84 is that him at the top oh this looks
terrible Randy's saying Patterson needs
to score oh hit him he's wide open
[Applause]
oh god oh no this is not on him this is
on Mariota he's been my Maxwell play
yeah I did the the fantasy phase
you ruined my fantasy team this year I
reach for him for what well you reach
for Mariota or pitch oh okay pit stand
bro it's brutal it wasn't him it's
Mariota
where's 84.
I see it mean next to the quarterback
hit him he's open
oh my God oh my God they're gonna call
holding that doesn't count as a catch
though it doesn't but it does put us in
field goal range
but
I just don't know what to do anymore
okay I can't do this
no stall give me two honestly they need
to throw a screen to pitch to get
something back like just like hey you
guys can throw the ball to each other
because Mariota has done the ball
nowhere near can't touch them after five
yards
I'm sending out alerts cheeky hilarious
let's go once in a while let's go tell
everyone Twitter in your alert uh yes
just follow Brad rice don't do it unless
you want to read about you Football news
don't do it seriously all right here we
go do it um they've committed to the
pass
the coach
I have yeah I mean I have different
rooting interests but yes
Falcons are plus four and a half live
right now
where's 84.
on the bench where he belongs
how's your field goal boys
here anytime yep oh no yeah I was here
yep that's running hard
hey Ryan 13 more brother I think yeah 15
more amen 14 more maybe it's not great
for Patterson it's okay hey he's no no
no no no he's coming back in oh it's
fine it's fine it's fine I think they're
gonna only use them in goal line
[Music]
[Laughter]
Vikings Cowboys there you go didn't even
look it up look at this point out there
no he's not
out of the game
Huntley Caleb Huntley for what why for
why
that's a hard run
no no oh no no he's not getting in no no
no come on you want to know why yeah
we're in The Dead Zone that's what uh
like we're we're a little ahead of the
Dead Zone
a young way now here we go here we go
bringing the buddy is it Cordell though
we need him I know we need him yeah we
need Cordell I I know we need Cordell
but is it him coming in the game no it's
not a question
I didn't know if it was him
oh my goodness here we go yeah this is
it this is it Cordell if it's play
action I'm gonna cool cry yeah I will
cry
oh flag yeah no it's personal wide open
foreign
[Laughter]
this is the worst possible thing it
could ever happen to me
did you bet the balance on the field no
okay
enforce it on the kickoff it's like does
he not look for 84 when he's trying to
throw the ball here's why it opens him
wide open way easier to throw yeah all
right
yeah watch look at this
I love over three and a half Kyle Pitts
the difference
it would have been the easiest touch out
of the night or no that's not updated
Drake London oh my God bro that would
have counted to seven yards too I think
that's what I'm saying
Necessary Roughness dude that's rough
that was a terrible unnecessary
roughness call that way young way
sideways
one through six and Panthers to cover
because now we're on the number you're
we're on the numbers
oh it's too much it's too much math plus
Eight's still looking good
oh my God that's unreal bro all right I
got a question for the gang yeah what do
we got Josh Allen hurt
could be severe
give me a MVP candidate or MVP pick
I I don't think that Chiefs team is like
going to have Josh Allen's probably done
for a while it sounds like I got to be
patching from homes but I don't love the
values uh
I want you to look at me dead in the eye
yeah Gino Smith Gino Smith what a psycho
pull ups pull up to MVP odds he's not
even a problem
there's no way no nothing's on the board
right now
I don't think we can look we can't fight
anyways it's not insane you think MVP
MVP
Pat Mahomes Pat Mahone he ain't going
crazy I'm trying to be a chalk eating
weasel over here I mean I like my boy
Gino Jet's Legend I'm right Jaylen hurts
Jalen I have a discussion for us I'll do
I'll do Jalen hurts our boy Ritter's got
Kirk Cousins he's all the Kirk Cousins
no honestly that's that's a good
discussion to talk about yeah because I
was I was all over Ritter
there we go damn it bring up bring up
DraftKings
Gino Smith 22-1 where is he he's ten
seven he's behind Joe Burns yeah how's
he behind Joe Bro that has to be a
liability thing they just have to have a
ton of jokes
it is plus four thousand so there is a
value on on
Ritter cash out now there's no way stop
programming drive to Illinois pass out
brother
okay so I love the Jalen hurts pick and
that me and Vince are on Jalen hurts
simply because their schedule is super
or something he's gonna have to be in
the discussion at plus 250. I know Ryan
hates Philly but it's true man that's
true now you're right
every time I make one request yeah every
time I say guys they're gonna win 15
games
Tyreek Hill is at 10. that's pretty
crazy
to break the offensive player of the
year for sure yeah yeah definitely
so I'll let's see where he is yeah how
is Tua higher than him
because he throws it to him but he was
hurt like yeah
it's a Quarterback Award it is what's
this offensive player of the year when's
the last time I went to it Kyrie plus
300 yeah
was it was it Adrian Peterson
he's got kick it up that's the only
person I could think of who got kick it
up yo bowling
he got to pick it up we'll probably pick
it up yeah did you guys see last game I
saw last game Greg I'm talking about a
body of work I need a little bit more I
know what you're saying but my man's
been bawling I need a little bit more
Tyree kills Ballin every week
jayes had like one bad yeah yeah it was
a watch it's a touchdown number she's
only got three touchdown numbers that
might be the only nah yeah
three I'm pretty sure he had two going
into the Bears game
all right what we got he's got already
over a thousand Greg a thousand yards
six minutes left in the third quarter
baby
and there's a run
all right I like what the Falcons are
doing in the second Falcons have woken
up big fan of what they're doing in the
second Falcons have woken up we all got
a lot of second half bets on the Falcons
besides Vince
I see Vince refreshing his DK oh man we
all got our pregame bets algeer bolin's
been knocking down live game uh bets
in-game Bets with Bryson
uh bagel and locks is back there locked
and loaded I'm doing all right not as
good as I'd like to be but
um Drake London has life I need an
Algeria anytime TD anyone but DJ who is
that not dj oh Terrence Terrence
Marshall Terence Marshall Terence
Marshall oh my God that boy almost broke
it is over receiving yards just hit for
sure my favorite part of it these are
like 20 and a half yeah huh four and a
half yeah I'll take that though over oh
there you go I was looking at it uh
before the game too it was very tempting
um we've got Jack and back in the garage
DJ Moore was wide open up the field
look at this attempted Tackle by 27.
this is decoy what are you doing he's a
decoy hey man it's a big decoys yeah big
decoy guys
what do you everyone needs a decoy Jack
comes in the chat saying Mahomes MVP
easy Ritter responding to us about Kirk
Cousins burrow in front of Kirko is so
insulting oh oh oh oh my God as soon as
I compliment the Falcons they don't want
to tackle no more unbelievable
what a mess it's true can Grady Jared
get some pressure bro
foreign
oh my God my favorite part of the chat
has been that some people are upset that
we don't immediately know some players
on the Panthers and Falcons
traded away McCaffrey I was like I know
nobody
this is what I said like oh that's so
funny when Rasheed Shaheed or whatever
scored that first touch on everyone's
like how do you not know this guy well I
live in Kansas
okay and let me tell you how many
Panthers games have been on television
in Kansas zero yeah zero yeah that was
sorry and when you don't score
touchdowns you're not in Red Zone either
right
exactly that's why I know Xavier Woods
because they're always on defense
come on
go hold up I'm not trying to wrestle
that guy nope
Greg you taking this guy
oh he does the absolute output too he
looks like a doodle
bring him back
red card did you get your PIN you got
Panera already yeah you're good yeah I
feel pretty good
the largest lead on their 14 and a half
lock
was that what it was it was 14 and a
half yeah that's tough
I didn't take it though
how much time you got Greg I see four
minutes left in the third like I won't
lie Ryan we're in like real scary hours
for neither team to score 25 if they get
a touchdown here yeah but they won't I
agree I tend to agree there uh Sam back
in the chat again saying Panthers kind
of so Panthers kind of sick he's left
two types of comments either Panthers
kind of sick or degrom to fill in Team
Villain team anybody yeah okay we are a
PJ Walker interception away from huh a
PJ stinks and tweet
[Music]
yeah it it very much might be over I
mean shoot I need a check mark Vince I
need to see one win
oh
that's a good throw that was very yeah
Falcons are
yeah
XFL money in here because I used to PJ
Walker was cash and best smell like a
good time for a pick
that boy hit the B button
really loose with that ball yeah we'll
see I would have loved to turn over
right there b button Xbox yes yeah yeah
I got both so oh Circle
winners only
I got a boat okay
oh that's a tough move
that was nice
he almost did it again Falcons don't
tackle oh Jalen Daniels
uh Ritter uh Trey Turner to the Cubs no
oh you're not free agency is open
I gotta look
he's trolling me because he wants Wilson
Contreras Sam saying pooper to the Mets
no
the brakes
the Braves can keep bloopers I still see
panthers kind of sick I'm not gonna
lieuten is Mr Matt the top five mascot I
don't know debatable bloopers of minor
league mascot
he looks like a torn up a year like the
type of teddy bear that you would find
out
who hit the clothes yeah no no I don't I
don't want the teddy bear yeah and his
Twitter's trash I don't know I don't
know closed captions come from on the
team Jay Jackson saying DJ more
touchdown oh
ah Bryson that's Foreman yeah yeah
that's Foreman all right
Falcon's gonna go for two
dang he's in the stands drink the beer
man you're in there man
that feels like 15-yard penalty
that's excessive celebration up there
seems excessive and he just tore his ACL
just kidding
he looked like he was getting carried
out that was excessive this is good for
the DJ more under though they're not
gonna throw away yeah the problem is
he's still stuck on like 28 yards right
yeah the problem is our Falcon stuff
because I mean they have to run though
right because they can't throw yeah
well we know the Falcons got a score so
uh they need to score in bunches they do
need to score a bunches
that could be big that's big that's the
second mission
we do we got plus eight oh we can't get
another field goal we're fine we're good
this
is beautiful
all right Falcons are seven and a half
live again
seven and a half yeah
I really just want the Falcons to win
Dodgers set over 41 and a half live
maybe it's back yeah we would need 14
more points is that that's two teddies
is that how that math works yeah I don't
think so yeah I think Falcons score on
this drive that's over the original one
I just met you
um and this is crazy
I'm trying to anybody think you guys are
dancing but I want I'm talking about
money do you think the Falcons score
this drive or what
Falcon strives all plus money punt plus
140. touchdown no plus 245 field goal
ten plus three ten what are we doing
turn over turn over on downstairs safety
Plus 475.
offensive scores plus 125 no offensive
score minus 165. okay so the door is
open for a field goal because they're
down 10. you still need to make the
field goal you have to make the field
goal
all fit yeah all right so it's like I'm
gonna put my I'm gonna put my life on
the line for this I'm gonna bet
touchdown and it will be to Cordero
Patterson
I like that all right just to win 69
that's good how much what nice Vibes
would you bet touchdown on this drive
and you you said it's gonna be recorded
why would you not just bet Cornell
products the next touchdown you do it
and we'll split the money
Lakers sorry Kyrie
no way
stop it stop it no not even funny no
no
I'm looking in the BR betting Community
right now I'm seeing a lot of just need
Patterson just please Patterson there
goes Foreman let's go Patterson this is
the time
a lot of parlays today needed both of
them to score Mad Dogs we just need to
hit our Squad ride mad Dodger saying the
field goal is the best choice yeah we
need the squad Ride app Community needs
the Squadron
BK says or Uncle Mal says is super lotto
and Community is super alive yeah he's
got a 10 to win seven G's I think let me
drag that boy over Sam's saying that
missed extra point ruined my life
not dramatic at all sounds right right
up his alley yeah Jay Jackson sank
turnover on this shrive that would be
plus 475.
no here we go offensive scores minus
165. 50 left a minute 50 left in the SEC
third quarter third quarter yeah we're
tracking on the second half bet no no
don't whisper it Vince yell it to the
rooftop well because I felt the momentum
was going the other way but now this is
uh
that was a hammerlock Ritter Patterson
for the For the Love of All That is Holy
yeah we need Cordell Patterson we need
it
Saturday being the coach I think he's
about to go play Madden good hire yeah
they're gonna go get blasted by the
Raiders which is going to say a lot dude
good higher they don't even have a guy
that called he wasn't even in the only
thing when he calls just run the ball
with Jonathan Taylor hey how do you
respect somebody that wasn't even in the
building the whole year but then they
come in out of nowhere and now they're
they're well he was coaching High School
yeah he wasn't in their building he was
in the upper quartile of the upper
quartile of the upper quartile of High
School coaches yeah it's true
throw it to him it's pets
I believe go go I would like to ask is
there a better decoy in the NFL than
Kyle Pitts I don't think so no I mean
he's been incredible maybe maybe DJ
Moore they're both on the field
DJ Moore could be a better Decor that's
honest no they don't respect DJ more
they go out there and they say we don't
need to cover this guy not great also
too I just want to see the two went
right out after each other in our
fantasy draft for work I remember shout
out to Sam uh DJ Moore want the pick
after Kyle Pitts in our Fantasy Draft
also Ryan we are okay 84 in the slot
hours for uh I need a kid yeah I would
agree with that
come on no not negative yards
positive yardage for sure
I'm telling you I think he was down and
that doesn't change anything because it
already happened not a magician
wow coming from the clouds as the voice
is upset I'm angry man
what how many punts are there man I'm
really did it stop raining looks like it
stopped raining
Patterson does not know anybody I'm just
thinking they have two bags in the game
it's algae 30 seconds oh this could be
big for the receiving yards if they plan
on throw is that just lining up in the
slot garage
he's got a decoy or a linebacker on him
look at Pence they're not even covered
that's a mismatch they know he's a
defense he didn't get off hit it throw
it away they're looking at the decoy
that was a pass it's a receiving area
receive it we're good it's all good not
good for The Vibes but yeah
honest question if you live bet if you
live bet like next play pass or run and
he gets sacked is that what is that
called does that pass
I'm seeing Desmond Ritter all over
Twitter yeah
the fans want Desmond Ritter yeah
I'm I'm in I want Desmond Ritter I want
anything else to be honest that wasn't
his fault I'll take bowling no that
wasn't America I seen him run but he's
made a couple questionable decisions as
far I got a good arm now prices say less
I don't know if I don't got his big
enough to be our betting Greg can I see
that ball you guys yeah is there is
there something Philly to Bryson where's
the football Bryson oh one second my
girl make sure it's in my range for what
how far I'm allowed to walk Bryson is I
got it
I didn't know we had a football here
this whole time oh yeah yeah I could I
could spend that's a game I brought the
props you know it I think I could spin
it
are we gonna do a turkey Bowl
this time
in Chicago
in Jersey uh we got a field yeah turf
field hey why don't we go to uh
California where it's sunny
and it won't be no elements
all right I was saying this the other
day when Tennessee dropped from one to
five that if there if there's it's
raining during the game the game should
not count oh so if you lose it doesn't
wash yeah yeah this is there's way too
much I've ever heard no it's like
everything if the Falcons lose it
shouldn't count my bet should be void
and it shouldn't have counted way too
much
can I make it take way too much producer
Ryan stocks went way down
[Laughter]
has been like conspiracy theory he's
been a historic drop off if it weathers
outside your bet shouldn't count Play
games under a room only don't so only
don't only domes
yes don't speak about it the rainbow
Greg I'm just trying to get people
winners I feel you there's a lot of
people like myself who bet on the
Tennessee Volunteers this past weekend
and got absolutely cooked I mean why'd
you do that I was the most public vet in
the entire day
doesn't go off come on that defense is
nasty I'm just saying
Georgia they do it for baseball all of a
sudden we do it for football and it's oh
it's a bad take oh it's a bad take it's
if Justin Herbert throws any passes your
bet doesn't cash yeah he's just too good
at it that right you can't have it you
have to do what if it's raining and and
Justin Herbert
uh
Vince
that's a that's a double void
football
uh the this past summer we went to uh
trip to Cape codger absolutely
it's not bad we reached the fourth
quarter Oh wait we're in punting Zone
hey yo come on down by 10.
where's 84. come on come on oh no it's
oh my God all right that's terrible oh
it was wet that shouldn't count
shouldn't count voice
except the unders the unders should
count
[Music]
like if you see there's nobody towards
the middle ability your route I can do
this all day oh God so sit down yeah you
give me you give me a low scoring
football game you're gonna get I am one
pun every Theory I have
20 yards so here's the deal the Falcons
need to to Buck up here yeah I mean this
is the game like if you can't make a
stop
I love this note that they're showing
like this is gonna happen again I don't
yeah I mean we have not happening we
have the man the man 10 500 Ryan
probably thinks the NBA bubbles the only
valid title
[Music]
the vet should be voided
the Lakers want it so the Sabers I would
normally say that because there's no
distractions hold on we'll get a play
here hey do you know
hold hold bringing it back bring it back
that's good vibes for us almost broken
also DJ Moore's unders are looking
phenomenal uh the Lakers want it so no
the same way the the Major League
Baseball Championship the World Series
the Dodgers won it so it doesn't count
right
if the Celtics holding on a run play
wait I was holding on the defense bro
that's pretty rough wait
they've got to put Desmond Ritter in
because they have nothing to lose I'm
sorry like I mean that's quite simply
though the worst punt I've ever seen I
honestly can't believe that Desmond
Ritter hasn't gotten playing time yet
because that boy cooked since he yeah he
is yeah
got him in the cups
and also too look what the other player
from since he's doing the league five
though
yeah they're they're four and five
yeah it's still bad I'm sorry it's bad I
mean I'm not disagreeing saying that
it's not bad but I'm just saying like
they're not doing one last thing and
I'll admit obviously hindsight's 20 20.
but why did we bet on the running back
in his overs and stuff on a team where
they have four running backs when you
have one team that has one running back
and he has 100 yards now thanks for
bringing this knowledge to us after I
mean I mean
yeah they scored touchdowns
oh my God there's five of you
they don't tackle bro they don't tackle
like you get a chance and I was trying
to even everyone who hit somebody and
you just want to the wave of positivity
around the Falcons at the end of the
half was just absurd to watch and
everyone drank the Kool-Aid dancing on
our groups
hold up uh it's bad it's bad
of course it's bad
nothing is going to win anything no
think about this game I'm not gonna win
anything except the Falcons drove the
ball down the field to close the person
that was it
wow I'm gonna definitely go oh for five
today oh for five yeah oh
oh what is it 12 minutes left who in the
Chad told me to bad Falcons ml all right
who was it that I listened to they said
oh it's Moody baby Moody baby said
points are for babies the points are for
babies
that's a good line though that's a good
shot
for babies oh God tickle him I mean he
it's just that was a great right
everything it's over
it's yeah if they take a field goal we
need it looks incredible guess what he's
gonna get a 40-yard Kyle they're they're
getting this they're making first
Contact like all the time it's a big
bull getting these chunk games that's a
big boy
it's getting stronger with every run you
got to do more than make contact like
you gotta yeah I'm tackling bro can't
arm tackle guys 230 pounds 50 pounds uh
Sam Panthers are kind of sick
oh oh that was all right all right now
okay so if you get stuffed here and
you're the Panthers what do you do you
go for it go for it how much time we
have left they got to do that again 11
minutes 12 minutes
Gotta Wait
gotta wait till this graphic goes off
I'll give you a game time update bad
timing for the graph good day to bet the
unders
yeah
11 40. wow we're cooking dude wow oh
dude I forgot we got that 25 too oh no
that's it it's over okay
okay so the game's over the game's over
all right all right talking somehow
meltdown the money line
stuff can we check in on what the points
are for Atlanta because I have a
last-ditch effort here uh they are plus
12 and a half
and it's plus money
don't make me act up
don't do it uh plus 1300 live money line
wait what's up
but why do you Tee It Up like that
this is an intonation of your voice back
them up back them up
good heart
excuse me I was back plus 1300 live can
we get the live lineup let's get it up
all advances plus 1200 oh now back damn
so they gotta they got at least four
yards
plus 12 and a half
anybody thinking about it I look at the
money I'm waiting to see if they score
here yeah I'll take the big number yeah
I heard points are for babies so I heard
the shirts are in production
plus 1300 that's how you feel it my bank
account you think that Mariota is really
coming four yards like I said great
what's that I think Mariota really
coming back no
come on no I don't I don't know why I
said it I regret it I will say a few
minutes producer Ryan stock yeah
just took another hit I think I'll hit
every I I won't hit [ __ ] the fudging
[Laughter]
should I double down Falcons ml now you
think plus 1100 now I mean the turnovers
plus 1100. your number is coming are we
getting a tfl we did bet on a PJ Walker
turnover we did I get a Grady we did
throw down I don't know if he's gonna
throw oh
that's the only play they got huh it's a
good play
where's the ball okay
all right we need to stop at 1007.
need a stop
uh Zach Eason
chat bowling hitting every live band
missing every every pre-game bet was
trash every live bet was pretty damn
good jtac saying we're cooks.com plus
1300 now I'm pretty sure they converted
that's another good shirt that's pretty
good that's a good shirt honestly boy I
have no worst feeling in the world than
I didn't get in that first uh play first
down bet with you but I was so lucky
dude
this looks like a first down to me oh
Grady oh no
oh okay okay
well most the biggest
snack though so that would have been
that would have been tough does anyone
need any more that's what I thought
maybe
he is very liable to miss
y'all Eddie don't forget that he stinks
that was
bad snap
he got it we're good we're fine
it's all good I Panthers cover and
Falcons win is looking good that's all I
have to say it is the only hard part is
that Falcons are down 13.
yeah I know okay so all the Kyle Pitts
haters in the room Ryan
and this is a bad deal for you because
you know now they're not running the
ball so Alger I think is toast
Cordero Patterson hopefully we get to
one the one yard line what
they're gonna have to throw to somebody
yeah it's probably gonna be Securus you
gotta get open dude
they know it was a gooey bet on Mariota
interception right now because
this has interception written all over
it if I really put my balance on it I
will break even is there any take about
even just turn over on Downs though or
like turnover is for minus 105.
no way yeah okay okay okay here you're
here let's go let's go to DraftKings
Mariota wait he has one interception
already he does yeah uh to over one and
a half interceptions is Plus 290. that's
pretty fun
plus 110 now for turnover or safety or
turnover on Downs
I kind of like that at plus 110. all
right I need a chat's take on this
because I'm seriously taking her on
Downs plus 110. it's pretty it's pretty
nice looking
um foreign
I mean you know they're not punting
right they're not kicking a field goal
right it would be so funny those are the
only two outcomes right touchdown and
and turnover on Downs Scotty boy saying
that's a good take man you don't get
analysis like that anywhere else oh my
God
see like this that's right
I don't have one check mark
my uh not one
see I need to be talked into it yeah
another interception
to then reward the person it eventually
cash okay
he has not been playing well
it's just so strange
he went through him like it's almost
it's almost
destroying at least one interception
before the end of this game that's what
I'm saying the ball is wet
bowling what is it this is how you use
the weather to your advantage the ball
is wet he's going to throw another so
the beds should be voided that's all I
know if he doesn't throw another
interception then the bishop
Ryan's betting rules my rules I think
her my rules I'll I'll bet at the Ryan
book first oh yeah dude do it right now
Teddy hey why not come on touchdown come
on oh man is he running like that man
that's how he runs we need 12 yards
922 left in this game
dude they have to like the only way they
move is running it his head's behind us
there's enough time where it makes sense
to do he needs he needs to break they
won't do it this way we'll do a next
drive if they get the ball back with
like five minutes
I can't Envision themselves three
quarters as well not on the screen you
know like it's just not gonna happen
there's too much rain not to keep going
back at this point Cordell Patterson to
get a catch come on
yeah it's tough it was rolling out there
anyone but Kyle oh who is that not Kyle
that's definitely not Kyle definitely
not Kyle third string Ted Michael Pruitt
his name is spelled m-y-c-o how did
Mario throw one pick in college and now
he can barely complete a pass five yards
down the field
because he's old and washed it's a great
question because he threw the ball a lot
of screens in college a lot of screens a
lot of Slants quick stuff yeah
what was that that he just threw um
quick stuff well that was a terrible
pass
got something for you Ryan I know
[Applause]
but they're gonna see that's the success
though so they'll just keep doing that
let's go Falcon I agree I think Huntley
looks tired
get them out get a breather bring it out
Cordell Patterson scoring a one-yard
touchdown we'll save this knight from
nah bro that'll be love I'm not an algae
I'm gonna ride with him
I need it I need Algeria like I need air
dude take Huntley out he's tired yeah
he's gas he's got a family at home dude
he's so tired get him on the plane how
much time yeah just eight minutes wow
they're still all right plenty of time
over over an interception I'm running
with Uncle Mal I need more you got
Mariota entire game yeah yeah Mariota
pick I like that he said over one he's
going to get desperate he already has
one he's already got one oh yeah yeah
he's gonna get desperate
it's the Oracle what happened
the elements again Ryan that's what I'm
saying
honest question honest honest honest
honest to God questions just look at
Kyle Pitts don't hear me out honest
question it's about to be so honest dude
where could I bet targets because Kyle
bids Target's over is a lock they look
at him a lot he just don't throw it
complete it they gotta run the ball with
algier though oh my God we have to have
like four interceptions dropped tonight
yeah and the thing is too I need a
panther's punt so bad guys you just
don't understand Alger algier this is
four down Terrace oh no no no no
no
there is no way
this dog there's no way no I think he
got that off he was down did you get
that did you lock that in I know it was
locked he was down
here
to 25.
00
what are you doing bro
at this point hear me out though what if
he completes it for a touchdown though
that's like the sickest play of all at
this point what are you doing punt the
ball oh you have turnover on down spawn
can we talk about how impressive it was
that he just chucked it 30 yards on his
ass that was pretty good I was gonna try
it that's the second best uh incomplete
pass I've ever seen behind Patrick
Mahomes told him I can't believe this is
down Uncle Mal had the Reeve yeah I know
I know I know I wasn't yo Greg they
don't have their best I just want to say
you really close to cash in that Bryson
over one and a half bathroom breaks real
close
drink too much water bro you over there
pounding Waters
real close he's hydrated as hell though
you got seven more minutes away I'm
hurting bro
[Laughter]
what a mess dude
over one and a half pounds of the
century in the in a live stream quad
dive with lead pipeline I need five more
Drake London yards
here you're gonna get him on this first
down right here even um
one of their best players is Cordell
Patterson why isn't he consistently on
the field
everyone's got to be banged up someone
new he plays multiple positions I'm I'm
sweating man I want this Mariota problem
you know I probably second game back
from injury right so it's raining it's
short week
they probably you know what's the decoy
get him in motion get the defensive ball
you goof
all right Drake London
oh no this is terrible because they're
not in hunting right I'm dead I lost
lost my pump bet
this is hideous bowling just cash I did
I did okay
or plus one ten yeah that was a lock bro
I knew it okay wait wait I had uh
turnover on Downs turnover or uh safety
I want to call specifically to Uncle Mal
here oh yeah because he had he had the
over one and a half uh Mario and
interceptions here I'm gonna go back to
it give me one second but right now I'm
seeing on my phone at plus 370. do you
still like it because once it opens up I
will ride with you
he just did hold up he's got
I'm sure
he's bound to throw something in the air
okay
you're on the 40 bro and we have under
now you're not at all no we're fine
we're good what okay so hear me out hear
me out yikes I don't think that they're
gonna kick a long field goal because
that's going to give the Falcons an
unnecessarily short field but all they
got to do is get one for us down yes no
I know we need a three I need a three
and out like I beat oxygen I need to
punt dude that's like a win-win-win-win
yeah okay whenever the Mariota stuff
comes up I will be but it's it's plus
370 right now but it's just locked so
uh I want that I want it bad
I want it Greg I needed it go get it I
wanted it there
I'm better don't make me bag it's there
for you to take I will bag no I will get
it I need Uncle Mouse take where is he
he said take it now Ryan hell yes and
yes
oh I need it
but I
I'm getting flustered
Panthers to give up a sack
plus five anyone else riding with Uncle
Mal I'm I'm trying where is is it open
I I don't know is so pumped he said hell
yes run it
I love Uncle Mal's passion yeah but this
thing is not unlocked it's plus 370 and
they're not letting us do it
this is tough
I also think I made a mistake I I bet I
bet them to punt
and they're on the 40. man so that's
real stupid
I need a sack really bad
somebody take my phone I was doing so
good Bryson
oh my God I just messed up something
what'd you do I bet that the Panthers
were gonna put
they're on the 40. oh yikes hey man get
a stop they might I need a sack I I need
another punt too what do you guys think
this drive result is so we'll go on so
bad just hit him just hit him this is
good okay they're gonna run it all three
plays right all right what's the yeah
they should what's the time right time
now
field goal attempt is plus 100 touchdown
plus 250 turnover turnaround Downs or
safety doesn't safety's not happening
plus 600 or put plus 425. I got a bad
number on the punt
wait punt right now is plus 425 yeah
get in with us Vince that's pretty good
that's a good that's like no here comes
the first one I'm like honestly like why
would you not just pin him back
if this is a short game here oh my God
did you get in at plus 475 no dude oh my
God oh my God don't tell me what the
live odds are this is big take the take
the lives off it doesn't get bigger than
this it doesn't get bigger than that
also for DJ more purposes
105. it's plus 105 to be a pun okay it's
locked down yeah Falcons are cut okay
Falcons are goats
I'm serious like I don't think the
Panthers are scoring another come on
bowling come on boys come on come on
come on
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no backwards go backwards let's go
let's go let's go let's go kick that
ball
oh my character flaws I'm a really hard
high five that's too much I'm sorry I'm
sorry my hand's red you got a medic we
got a medic
the theme of this the theme of this live
stream has been Ryan at least it's mine
whether I actually win the better not
great
I got it at plus 300.
you didn't touch him no no no no no no
no
[Applause]
what are the odds okay so turn over to
it's not good Vince turned over turn
over on Downs or safety is minus 195.
that's a lock though because that's
gonna happen
I don't know I just won 80 bucks on the
punt pay me out so I can put it on
touchdown I'm feeling crazy now
well they're not gonna
they're not gonna Pawn can't can't bet
the the uh Mariota interception so this
is how you would do it uh and that's
it's not enough hey I don't know NFL
fans want Desmond Ritter they do they're
calling they're calling for death could
you see Desmond Ritter here why not
gotta see what he's got to wait in the
game
you mean to tell me there's no chance
that the Falcons score a touchdown here
we still have hope in the chat for a uh
a Patterson t-day from Larose Garza I
should I kind of feel like it yeah we
still had some positivity here
what about the back I'm that guy though
about the back row how do we feel about
Cordell Patterson right now oh he's gone
it's done oh see my vibe over here this
has optimism oh the chat still has
optimism yeah the chat Bryson this is
right up your house Falcons Drive no
offensive score minus 750. see I like
offensive score here bro plus 500 though
I think they might drive bro he said
right up your alley minus 750.
walk out of bed bro wait up yeah I agree
yeah
hey Brick by Brick huh
dude like I said earlier Ryan owes me
like 50 bricks so
this is the Ryan osme show it is I'm
just saying change the title change it's
not a big deal but I'm just saying
I think both are plus money too right
yes dude you will get your money though
I'm getting ahead of myself I'm getting
ahead myself because the Panthers could
easily like get a like get something
crazy here and score it's like I'm
actually getting way ahead of myself
you're about to say safety and then you
did math well they they get the ball
back you know whatever could happen I
need to get it back unbacked out of this
end zone before I think that that's it
I haven't paid my punt out yet
I'm trying to get more live bets in is
that all year 84 is still not out there
yeah I was oh
cool bro Mario
I'm gonna pretend I bet uh Kyle Pitts
over eight targets so yay me my Maxwell
play though yeah Jesus
man bro this isn't even about Kyle Pitts
bro it's about Marcus Mariota Beach he
likes facts the ball is wet okay don't
get paid millions of dollars they would
have to right his game how much time
left five minutes well they go for it
well honest to God
Alger Algeria Algeria they gotta run
they gotta get yards
oh
oh my God you're going to make London oh
my god
oh yeah it has to be baby I'm glad
somebody's cashing good stuff let's go
I'm so scared right now
we need a what I ended up taking uh
uh turnover oh on this drive yeah
or it was turnover it's minus 200 now
yeah or yeah turnover run down Greg we
need a touchdown here like we need air
for the uh plus eight
bro we need all right we need a miracle
this one just run baby
oh man that was actually yeah that that
saved a lot of yards like a gazelle
though hey he should have been doing
that jumped
come on hey touchdown's big here for the
second half cover though oh they're
faking injuries now man stop the clock
is that Xavier Woods I need a tuddy I
need a falcon study
did you take the 13 and a half
Falcons there
Falcon study I might take Falcons plus
they're two and a half pounds 500. he's
looking good I'll take it I got seven
and a half too and money line
I loaded up on Falcons when that guy in
the chat said too
and I'm we're hanging out too this is
what we're doing
ah
oh my goodness
defensive coordinator so this is your
team well I've learned a lot about
myself today I should not bet before the
game I should only BET live in the game
yeah got to because I'm over five on
pre-game friends and I'm probably five
is there any chance we can show everyone
the bet so they can see that I'm 5-0
right now are you 5-0 yeah are you 5-0
Is that real yeah punts cashed right I
feel like something else up there cash
right or no
Ryan you know what I'm kind of feeling
Panthers plus threes of cash you
probably could just Kyle pizzas about it
why did you catch that that was so nice
that's a forward pass let it hit the
ground you were six yards behind the
line
just clocked eyes yeah that's that's a
weird what were you what were you
feeling I think Kyle Pitts might do it
to US 60 seconds options
um I have receiving yards under I might
think he might catch a bomb here oh okay
I have the I have the receptions and
Mariota can't hit anyone in the chest
oh boy
oh Demir bird wow the mere Birds over
under was ten he got it on the first
point stop throwing it to him
and he's out of bounds what we got four
minutes
um there's something around that
341. oh God
all right come on all right yeah clap it
off
let's go Fox
Tamir bird is the Oracle oh my God the
bird is him bro I'm telling you guys
right now the Falcons are going to win
this game I'm telling you this right now
let's go I'm hitting the middle bro I'm
hitting it I need it I need you oh God
the problem is is that if they do when
you see I'll probably go for two to try
it
they'll try and go round 13.
pits
oh my God
Ryan
yeah
that's two cats I love how Ryan was
confident just fails in the first
quarter failed but two countries
I didn't say it's over I just didn't
know I need 10 yards
I need under 10. yeah no he's dead after
that one take him out yeah he's out he's
out that's good for me
oh no it's not Drake brag
I'm middling where I say the middle
cover I'm middling dare I say though
plus eight that's all yes I got seven
and a half baby tell everybody
[Music]
at halftime go for two ah no two no two
no they're going for two why no no two
they're going for two oh no they're
kicking they're kicking sorry also then
we're safe brother hey also guys we won
three timeouts what are you Middle with
three
I'm I'm betting a four I'm betting a
Falcons won the Falcons just won I'm
betting a three-time outs fellas
that was the worst possible scenario bro
oh my God poo
boy
that's bad bro
that's two times two consecutive lives
one job he showed up the football
practice and has one job you don't have
to do one thing kick the ball
oh my God that's miserable extra point
yeah that's bad
all right
I'm going back to the well gentlemen
this is brutal outside in here no no oh
he tipped it that was blocked that
looked good if we get OT if we get OT
Bryson over one and a half bathroom
breaks it's all smash
he only drank all his water too that
bladder is screaming right now
there's a graveyard of empty water
bottles
three times
I need a punt
oh boy all right oh my I'm telling you
dude honest question though honest
question for everybody Falcon score
touchdown they go for two just to win
the game
yeah yeah yeah you gotta think about it
100 you do got to think about it or even
at least go for two and try and get them
to jump off side off and then you gotta
and then go for it and they don't just
kick it
get him get him
okay it's not bad that's our boy they're
literally only gonna we gotta send the
freaking house yeah you gotta put that
10 on the line
say I'm saying I am broken
a Glenn needs a punt
I feel really bad for this plugged in
court at the Falcons that's an update
yeah Uncle Mal Ryan DK changed mariota's
props to over two and a half
interceptions do not
thank you thank you Uncle Mel what about
the under
Uncle Mel yeah yeah that's why he's our
captain
under minus ten thousand hey two minutes
and 50 seconds left
of the game I like them just get a stop
here it's it's it's it's it's a close
one we gotta see
second and six
bro come that's a good tackle that's a
great tattoo
please sorry producers if me smacking
the ball is bringing in everybody's ear
you said there's 246 left
[Laughter]
bathroom bro uh Bryson Uncle mouse
saying minus 1400 under one and a half
Mariota interceptions that's all that
you're all over that yes
but honestly though the Falcons get the
ball back which I think they're about to
because the odds just dropped on that I
actually think that that's not a lock
anymore
uh jackham's feeling okay we'll see this
place is gonna say everything as long as
it's not to DJ
how many are you gonna drop
bro don't have some pride bro you know
why it happened why do you even play
why'd he drop the ball Greg Cordell no
why did he throw it well
oh yeah I know what you're talking about
the elements because of the elements
Panthers score a touchdown I mean that
was it get the ball back in OT algae
hits
rushing yards they win elements
everybody's happy
um that's when you put Pat erson back
there games played in a dome it's an
interception uh how much time is left
220 2 30. this is the longest 33. they
could still listen to they can still run
the ball here too it's just a matter of
who moves the running back in the game
we can get the I need him to be on the
one or it's not gonna be a Patterson
This Is Us middling accordingly
has he even been in that's all in the
fourth quarter no it's not him has he
even Ben
he's been in the slot but he hasn't been
like nah the Golan play remember play
action that was the last time I remember
him yeah
they do
come on
oh batteries
this is bad yeah anyone but Kyle come on
anyone but Kyle oh my god oh you gotta
throw it away okay gotta run the one
thing you can't do all right Bryce is
gone whoever had over one and a half
bathroom breaks
you want a time how long it's gonna take
yeah okay we're under a minute
now I was gonna say
30.
I'm on it what do we got over under I'm
going under I'm going I'm going over now
the line's got to be better 115 now 130
130.30 take the under
you're he's giving me free money
how much you want that it said 20
seconds already yeah it's that 20
seconds you gotta find the bathroom this
place
it's like they don't know
no it's it's over 100 over it he has a
minute left
I trust him he just got back to he just
got to the bathroom this man's a hustler
he might not have even found the
bathroom yet hey if he makes it no way
he washes his hands
like zero zero zero chips
under 130 he washes
when he gets here did he wash those
heads if he's a smart guy you just you
run and you run and you hit the hand
sanitizer pump on the way yeah knock it
over we are at a minute right now yes
we're at a minute
oh
hello the line is too high okay
baby oh and you touched his
hands
away
oh you watched it
the real question is did he use soap
yeah 100
I don't know if I believe that oh it's
quick dude it's quick man
Ah that's all right oh you gotta dive
is that she us uh this is not good for
us dude this is not good game's over at
least we covered no pets here
yeah I mean well the cup yeah yeah it's
not over but it's looking good now Kyle
gets here right for first down bro no
you got plus eight right no pits 10
yards man yeah so 11 yards we somehow we
somehow cash my back down
depends bro uh Ritter jumping hey that's
seven just wash your hands oh you're
right yeah yeah you're right you're
right dude I'm all over the place right
now oh
my what a play
this game's over 150.
we're cooked bro they're gonna kick a
field goal no they're not yeah we need a
first down
oh you know it's down bad bro they're
not kicking the field though bro
actually yeah I don't think they would
bro
oh my God
I will say this is the first time I've
ever made money on DJ Moore
considering he's ruined my life the past
three years
well time to flip the narrative yeah
they're gonna kick the field goal
oh no please don't marry you know that
time we almost all bet young weiku uh
over at over five and a half hour
dude they I can't believe this
don't use it oh we need a first down so
bad Bryson
wait a second hey yeah first down this
is over they're perfect yeah so if
you're ice
just run around throw the ball leave
them 10 seconds left
anything bad can happen bro and we have
the life you're not but Eddie we have
the live we have the live plus eight
this is Young Lake who's fault yeah
that's what I was saying no I know we're
in trouble dude yeah
they're not kicking a field goal oh my
God only thing we're in trouble for is
the touchdown we don't want a touchdown
Greg if they can't go we're losing by
10. they're not kicking a field goal
that's what I'm trying to tell you get
it get it get it get it oh
inhale exhale we just need a first down
please cats all up they won't kick it
chat they won't kick it yeah they're not
kicking a field goal I was supposed to
put my faith in all these dudes Sam
saying zero percent chance okay Sam said
it Sam said it Sam said it yeah yeah
Sam's Mr analytics zero he said it zero
percent what about is there dvla
what about the dvoa just get the first
down that's all I can get the first down
and fall
[Applause]
oh no disaster it's fine it's fine
that's a disaster disaster
oh no he said
we wasted time though there's no way
it does I know but we still got 40
seconds at the end of this play
so we're 18 seconds between the play
clock game clock they're going to waste
four or five seconds here there's no way
to kick a field goal with 12 seconds
left there is a way they're 100 going to
no way no way
are goose is cooked where's this at
Caroline I'm getting the first one to
Carolina I'm gonna accept it you think
they kick a field goal yeah
and for those in the chat or one of me
and Ryan have neither team to score 25
points that's what we're sweating right
now this is so scary bro this is so skip
no way
back up and Chuck the ball check them up
in the air
too much time he's gonna call timeout
and kick three
he said hey come here
he talking to the uh to the ref he wants
to he wants to call timeout no if he
sends the field goal kick out there
that's a lot of risks that's a lot of
risk risk ain't no risk bro
they can botch the snap young yeah
though Eddie has been hitting him just
take a knee and play defense
what are the odds how much 14 seconds
do it but but you can't throw the ball
in the air for 14 seconds no you're not
wasting all the time begin until I eat
you run around wait till someone comes
you throw it up and take a safety all
the way back Bro yeah one of these
fumbles running back into the end they
sent eddiep out there Walker walk off
the field
no they didn't oh oh my God oh my God
he said zero percent he still said they
won't kick I promise okay it will not
kick not a chance
from Uncle Mal oh my and he's gonna miss
he's been missing all
right
this is it it's done
wait a second
oh my God
game over
that's crazy
my God that's great
yo Sam you're only 15 bucks brother
we'll move past this we'll move past
this 15 bucks
hand up Sam's got hand up in the chat
this is oh my God I tried to tell you
guys man he's he literally was like yo
come over here let me call timeout
coach has his kicker playing
oh my God
you know what Vegas called they had to
they had to why would you kick it there
that look
ERS head-butting people Sam without the
holes we wouldn't have kicked really
breaking news
Baker Mayfield's out their head but oh
man
that's funny that's great Colin
cowherd's gonna have a special on that
he touched it do something you watched
it
look in ladder time and this guy touches
the ball and does that
40-yard reception
The Vibes here are
it was going so well how do I
everybody Vibe is low besides Vince bro
if he said zero percent viral Vinnie and
this is what our producer
I don't disagree that's just not what I
needed to hear right now
thank you don't disagree
but bad vibes where's Kyle Pitts
he's not on the field please no Kyle
where's 84. not even Alger that is no no
it could have been 84.
yeah they don't even pitch it back L's
in the chat bro huh L's in the trash in
the chat Al's in the chat dog hashtag
bad beat hashtag badbeat in the chat
that's a legitimate one Sam's the one
that calls people out on the bad beats
that's legit yeah that's like bad beat
right side yeah game's over
a lot of money loss
but our heads are up high a lot of Vibes
a lot of Vibes and we're clapping it up
I'm walking Bryson probably has the most
money
to the bathroom the most walking across
the bridge
I'm walking in New Jersey no I'm just
walking right walking do you need me to
buy it
I might need it now buy you a Metro it
was fun though fellas yes sir I didn't
win no bets so I'm up out of here
because it's time to go yeah we're out
peace peace y'all peace y'all
wrong
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah yeah
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]